you revealed battlefield 2042 to the
world last month
how does it feel to have the news
finally out there oh well i i
think the theory is when you when you
build a game and you're kind of looking
forward to announcing it you're supposed
to feel excited and pumped and thrilled
and all those kind of positive words
yeah the honest reality is pure agony
the last couple of weeks
before you show off i think you know you
have teams that spend years and years
and years hundreds and hundreds of game
creators creating these games and then
you get this final moment
where you get to show the game to the
world and you never know what reaction
is gonna be but of course super happy to
be able to show the game to the world
it's something we're super
pumped about um so tell us about the
game and it's
trademark game events that are truly
next level you know
not many times in your career do you get
the chance to go through a console
transition so when we got the chance now
to work on the new generation of
consoles
it really enabled us to rethink some of
the kind of core
building blocks of battlefield
delivering a game at a scale we've never
done before
and it comes both on the land masses you
play battlefield on but also the player
counts you know getting the chance to
play with 128 players
on an army scale kind of warfare setup
we added a lot of really cool gear to
the game things like
grappling hooks wing suit and then for
some really cool reason we like to say
like what about a real-time tornado
real-time tornadoes are cool right what
about adding one of those to battlefield
and then what happens if you take that
and you combine it with a wingsuit so
you can kind of propel yourself to the
other side of the map
you know these tornadoes they kind of
help in cut a ground way when you play
uh
there's been more than a few play tests
in which you're in this really intense
situation where you're honestly pretty
screwed
and then a lovely tornado shows up and
just sweeps all the enemies in front of
you
like hey that worked high five mr
tornado
and i think those kind of really big
revolution moments that we're
introducing as part of balfi 2042 is
what makes the game special
you need to play on your toes every
single second because you never know
what mother nature throws at you
can you shoot like into and out of the
tornado of course you can shoot that a
tornado
one good way of understanding that the
storm's actually approaching is just
kind of looking up at the trees if
they're trying this you're starting to
bend a bit too much
you probably are supposed to start
running because you're gonna get you
know sweeped up for that tornado sooner
or later
can you tell me how long the team has
been working on the game yeah so this is
a three-year cycle for us and that
really has enabled us to both take a big
leap when it comes to tech so we're
running on a completely new version of
frostbite which has enabled us to push
both
visual fidelity and you know core
gameplay as a result
and really to kind of hone in on the
concept you've seen us talk about our
notepad specialists our new characters
and we've invested a lot of time and
kind of love and passion into the
storylines and the worlds and you know
the the war we're portraying uh so we're
super happy to get the chance to do that
so dice and dice la have had a long
history with battlefield
but before we talk about the history
dice la just rebranded
so can you tell us all about that
christian uh yeah so the studio was
formed eight years ago as a way of
expanding the capabilities that that
dice had to build battlefield
we wanted to push this idea that we have
in the studio where we really want to
drive
quality in everything we do as a studio
and in order for us to do that in a
really good way we believe that you need
to be good at listening you need to
listen to the people that work
in the studio to kind of find these good
ideas these kind of
nuggets of good ideas that we then try
to turn into something real
and that sort of is ripple effect for us
it's this idea that great things have
small beginnings and that's kind of what
a ripple effect
is but we're super excited about the
name we feel like it represents us
it flows well it's a good name uh so the
work that oscar
and christian have been doing for
battlefield hasn't even been revealed
yet but christian i'm hoping that you
can maybe give us a little bit of a hint
uh so i can't say that much about it
uh what i can say is this though is that
one of the components in this experience
that we're creating
is that we're adding some of the fan
favorite maps
back into battlefield 2042 but the
entire experience you have to wait a bit
longer before we
reveal what that is
the team at dice announced hazard zone
at the reveal but
didn't say much we know it's being
developed at dice can you tell us a
little more about that
yeah i mean so battlefield 2042 ships
with three core multiplayer experiences
we've shown off all our warfare of
course christian and his team has
something special coming shortly that
will show at ea play live
and our second experience is called
hazard zone it's a high stakes
squad based game mode uh with a lot of
high tension it's not your classic
battle royale it's
a really contemporary mode it's also
something the team has been thinking
about for many years
i'm really looking forward to showing it
to the world it has some really special
components and it really kind of leans
into the super power so
battlefield and dice at the same time so
we'll show more
later this fall just a couple of weeks
and months before we
launch the game in october so vince
you've been part of some of the biggest
fps games in the history of the genre
like medal of honor allied assault call
of duty and call of duty modern warfare
also the sequels to both of those
franchises titanfall 1 and 2
my personal favorites and apex legends
just to name a few
what is the secret ingredient to making
a great fps
a great team that was immediate i love
that
i think it goes back to something
christian uh mentioned which is
finding nuggets of of gold within the
team members themselves
and and um putting them into the game
right building a great team where people
are
uh you know have this initiative and
they're passionate about making games
ideas come from anyone and so if you put
the right people in place then
those ideas just sort of happen is
assuming you have a collaborative
culture and a place where people feel
like they can speak up and pitch ideas
and
not all ideas are good like you have to
be like we'll throw out ideas and
you know i'll say something and chad go
say that's stupid we're not doing that
okay and he's probably right most of the
time
what was the idea in apex that you guys
threw out
besides titan because we all know
everyone's been asking about titans
there's a lot coming off of titanfall 2
we had a lot of the titanfall 2
mechanics in the game like the titans
and that was something that we
decided to cut as well as wall running
and the jump packs
and i know those are all favorites of
titanfall players but they
added to what we call brownian motion in
our game where players can sort of be
anywhere at any time
and we wanted a slower pace more
predictable
combat where you know you can predict
when someone goes around the corner like
you know the
possibilities where they could be and
not and not that they can be anywhere
and then the titans just sort of you
know were a weird balance they were sort
of
how do you make them powerful enough
that you feel really cool when you're in
a titan but
not op we had drop pods at the beginning
instead of jumping out of the plane and
sort of doing the skydive
we had a map that you would pick where
you would drop and sort of just
instantly dart down in a drop pod but
you know we found during play test that
giving players more time to reposition
and see where other players are going
and rethink strategy
was more fun i'm going to check it out
over there it's a lot of play testing
and you know trying things and failing
fast and moving on or improving
if you see a promise in it so yeah i
think it's
incredible to see like your team work
together and like you said a great team
makes a great fps
because now you have this title that is
esports ready
and you know algs has been doing wonders
a lot of people have been wanting to
enter into it and so it's just kind of
the proof is in the pudding right
yeah we're really glad that people are
playing it competitively and algs has
been great
just held the championships so that was
really cool
really big prize pool so that's been
exciting looking forward to doing it
again next year
i know you mentioned your team with
ripple effect
now so would that kind of be your same
answer
yeah of course key is a great team i
mean that's how you succeed
the other thing that i really like is
and i think that's something that the
battlefield franchise has done well is
not being afraid of taking risks and not
saying no
instantly so if someone come up with an
idea like
having a tornado real time in the game
someone doesn't just say that's insane
cut
instead it's like yeah maybe that could
work and that kind of what if
question i think is super important to
take some risk like we introduced
destruction back in battlefield by
company one into the game
which wasn't necessarily from a
development point of view a sane
idea but it was a cool idea and we
wanted it so we kind of pushed for it
even though
it was really difficult to do but then
like like vin said you have to balance
that with the
being bold enough to cut things that
don't work as well and that is actually
more difficult than it sounds
it's difficult to cut things that you've
been working on for a long time so i
think that balance is really important
to strike
uh then turning to oscar is there
anything that you've had to cut from
previous games that you've worked on
that
kind of made you feel a little bit sad i
have one that i miss you know every
single day we'll hopefully get it back
in you know some battlefield version
it's actually something we did back in
the battlefield four days called tablet
commander
uh so you might remember you could
actually join into a 64 player
battlefield session on your tablet
either an android one or an ios one
and we even had voice over ip support so
you could kind of call in
supplies you know do a bunch of things
from the ipad and the reason i
remembered so well it was actually the
same year i got my first kid
so i couldn't sit in front of a console
or pc but what i could do is i could
carry my kid on one arm and i could have
my ipad another one i can scream at my
squad
and give them squad orders so we just
need to get tablet commander back and us
not having it in the next couple of
games is still really frustrating me so
we have to fix that
do you think we can make that happen
hopefully at some point it will be back
in the game i don't know though let's do
a classic christian
you you and i this weekend oscar let's
write some code
yes how hard can it be yeah i love the
commander feature as well that's a good
call-out oscar
so going back to apex chad and vince you
guys have been able to knock it out of
the park with
every season launch and i think season
nine was one of the best because
you also brought back titanfall 2's most
infamous pilot
viper with valkyrie and created this new
backstory for a character that we really
didn't get that much screen time with
how do you guys keep doing it
well our writing team just loves
titanfall
and they're trying it you know every
moment to try to squeeze something in
we've seen that the fans really love it
too
and so when there's an opportunity we
obviously want to do it the team is just
generally very familiar with all of the
characters and the universe and
and all the lore so sometimes it's a
natural fit and sometimes we just you
know
we'll pull in a ash to to run the the
arenas or something like that you know
it's all in the same universe so it
happens fairly naturally i think i saw
that you guys even pulled in
a community member to the writing team
right
i think that's incredible what was your
decision-making process on that
yeah as the game gets bigger and we've
got you know more
devs working on the game we needed to
really document and start cataloging you
know our lore and what we've done what
we haven't done and who's who
and so he had already been essentially
doing that for free
and so we just reached out and asked if
he wanted to work for us and uh yeah now
he works at respawn and he's sort of our
lore expert now
oh my god that's amazing yeah i mean the
universe is something that we're
building on and we have big plans for in
the future so it's really important that
we keep
keep our heads straight on everything
because it's not always easy
yeah and i i noticed that you also
brought in um i think
community artists for all the apex
panels and
even on twitter not even just in-game so
how do you
find these people these artists and who
how do you pick them
man they there's been so much good art
we don't ask for it they just they just
post it and it's amazing thank you all
it blows our minds so we've done a bunch
of things with the community and
honestly we're just getting started
we're gonna you know hopefully do a lot
more we've um reached out to a few
people and they've done some comics for
some of our seasons
we just partnered with someone in the
community to do an animated
pathfinder video game over
thanks for playing and yeah just getting
started there's so many amazing artists
out there
and you know we're also hiring so they
can always oh
they can always apply also but they're
doing great work that's amazing
yeah yeah i think that's amazing that
you've been able to tie the community
into this and kind of give back in that
sort of form i love it so much even the
casual comics that i see retweeted on
the apex legends twitter account i think
it's really cool that you've been able
to bridge that gap between people who
are
so passionate and aren't necessarily
developers or
in the gaming industry but they just
want to share their love of the game and
you guys have like embraced the
community which is
incredible yeah and we've been
partnering with them to actually
help get them actual lore so they can
release their own comics and things
that are that are actually you know like
a legit backstory and it's not just
their own creation but
yeah i think that's awesome some legends
fight for fortune
others answers but we shall all be
forged in the glorious realm mirage
quite what was the inspiration for apex
legends well
we were really passionate about making a
team-based game and
we initially were prototyping with
different classes and how do you create
team play
and so some of our early legends were
like lifeline you know being the combat
medic
pathfinder came over from titanfall 2
and sort of
naturally found some abilities that was
fun
but i think once we honed in on making
the game about
the actual legends not so much the
abilities or the or the gameplay but
more through the eyes of these legends
that's when the game really took off
from a development point of view
and and a lot of the team just got
really passionate about the
actual legends themselves and who they
are and then things start
lining up and making sense like why is
bloodhound doing these abilities and i
think that's when the team sort of
became aligned and started working
together
we took a victory yeah and i think we
were looking at what was happening kind
of as we
progressed after titanfall 2 like where
we would take multiplayer and
kind of looking at you know the battle
royale space and it kind of blowing up
and we wanted to take that and do
something new and unique with it
so kind of combining that you know the
character base play with that just made
sense
yeah and i think you guys said that you
want to expand beyond battle royale
which was evident in season nine's
arenas
can you guys give us a hint at what else
you might be planning going beyond
battle royale yeah so battle royale will
continue to be a primary focus for us
that's you know that's the roots of the
game but we have been trying to expand
beyond battle royale because we have
you know what we think is a really great
combat loop and a fun core gameplay um
and so we're trying to offer more ways
to play so we just released arenas in
season nine
and in season 10 i can confirm that
we'll be releasing a ranked version of
arenas
the rules are simple whoever survives
wins so i'm very curious what fps
defined you as a developer
so for me it's the first fps game i
shipped which was battlefield 1942
it took off became a huge success to
kind of everything there on that journey
building that game and experiencing the
launch
i mean it's one of the greatest i guess
memories i have in
my career so that's that's the game that
defined me i just realized
you launched with 1942 and now it's
2042 how do you feel about that i feel
really good about it so when uh
i love the the name um so i think that
was a great
uh choice uh going back to to our roots
in a way so i really
i love that name and i love it sort of
coming together
uh what about you oscar yeah i have to
go back to my classic
counter-strike days i know i spent
decades and decades it feels like in the
game i still like on a rainy sunday um
instead of actually playing like proper
multiplayer games i will just join an
empty dust2 server and i will work on my
smoke grenades just to make sure
i don't know why uh i haven't given up
in that you know given up on that dream
of becoming a pro player it'll never
happen
but it's still my go to game on a rainy
sunday and what about vince
i'm very curious um probably like
doom because the modding you know we
spent a lot of time like
making mods and trolling our friends as
we played you know kind of lan party
style
um and then playing probably quake three
arena was probably like
the game that i had the most fun you
know playing competitively do you think
you
could have gone pro in it oh gosh no
chad how about you yeah i'm kind of
surrounded by my idols here because
i grew up as far as multiplayer gaming
um playing a lot of battlefield 1942
and then um what got me my start in my
career is actually
playing and modding medal of honor
allied assault which is a game vince
made so um and then you know that's how
i met vince and got my job and all that
and started working on call of duty
how does it feel like hearing all this
right now uh
it feels really good of course yeah it's
great but i mean it's like we're all
fans of each other's work i mean i love
playing i like the salt
modern warfare was amazing i used to
play a ton of um
counter strike as well i think maybe
most of us did that was
that was a ton of fun so when are you
and oscar gonna team up for cs go
that's a good question i'm pretty sure
oscar is way better than than i am so
i don't know or maybe you can carry me
oscar yeah i think the five of us you
know on this call were all great in
theory at least and that's a really good
start
the question is if we can translate it
in a good place but maybe maybe we could
schedule something for this weekend we
just need to finish these games we're
working on
i think people assume that we're good at
the games like it's this weird thing
where you you put out a game
and instantly you have like an hour
window maybe where you you know you
know the tricks better than the players
and then they just surpass you like that
now
it's it's crazy actually i'm really
curious how many times like what what is
a moment where
you've seen a fan post gameplay of
something that you never thought was
possible in a game
every day every day is there like a
favorite moment what was the curved
bullet thing in titanfall
curved bullets i don't remember that one
yeah they used the warp thing and they
would curve bullets and hit people oh
yeah yeah i'm so glad i wasn't playing
against them
yeah anytime i release something new
also we think it's like really well
balanced and then we release it
and we just like oh no people are doing
that with it
um it's awesome love it okay what about
a battlefield moment because i know that
can get i mean you're adding a tornado
now so
what is what is one of the wildest
battlefield moments that you've ever had
uh i remember actually which was kind of
bizarre we were playing against a bunch
of journalists on bf 1942
early on and they took the b-17 and
started wing walking on the b-17 so the
entire
team flew on the b17 walking on the
wings that was an amazing moment that
like
we yeah we didn't even know that you
could do yeah i mean
i think one of the kind of magic pieces
when it comes to battlefields notion
like what people can do
in a social construct and i mean and
many are actually the easter eggs we
produce across the years about it really
are all about players coming together
and doing things together to unlock
something unexpected or crazy
so there's some magic source there in
battlefield that really works well with
the community
so earlier this year ea moved need for
speed to go all in on battlefield
can you tell us how that works with a
total of three studios and ea gothenburg
supporting specifically on frostbite
engine tech
yeah i mean i'd say on a normal year it
would be borderline impossible to pull
in that many studios to build a game
like this but i think
this covet environment we've been in
means that it's actually easier to scale
teams because we're all in the same kind
of infrastructure
zoom meetings virtual whiteboards
virtual platforms you know everything
has
the word virtual ahead of it so this is
by far the biggest battlefield team you
know we've ever had and that's really
enables us now to ship these like three
core
you know multiplayer experiences in part
to the balcony 2042 launch
uh but it's been a grand adventure a
couple of months left uh you know and
use kudos to everyone in gothenburg
guilford la and of course the team back
in stockholm you know everyone's come
together
and it's obviously not only those folks
there's been
engineers and artists and audio
designers from
kind of every single corner of the world
across electronic arts helping out on
this game and i think you've you've seen
it when you
uh you've seen the reveal trailer and
the gameplay assets it's really shining
through so
kudos and thanks for all the help
things are about to get mighty
interesting so
chad we're coming up on the next season
of apex already
what are some lessons you've learned
from the past year
yeah there's been a lot of lessons i
think from uh from a development
perspective you know make sure that
we're we're giving everything enough
time to to be good before it comes out
i mentioned earlier ranked arenas coming
next season that's one of those things
that just wasn't quite ready and so we
just pushed it a season
i think early on we were probably trying
to hold our to our guns and release
things on
schedule and now i think we just we're a
little bit more flexible with that sort
of thing and i think the players have
responded well to that
um you know we'd much rather release
something when it's really good
and ready than to just get it done on
time yeah i don't think everyone
realizes how much time some of this
takes like
characters are we've gotten it down now
to only about a year
yeah it's a little bit more yeah a year
and a half or so so
like we spend a lot of time kind of
honing them so it sucks to rush it out
at the end
you know with things we want to be able
to have the time to to make it perfect
or as perfect as we can
out of curiosity how long would a map
take to develop
we're generally about a year and a half
from when we first start doing
block outs to to shipping
what about map changes actually is that
any easier than doing full maps
updates it's definitely a lot easier
like a map update
is generally about six months so we're a
couple seasons ahead on those
and then a town takeover we're usually
about one season ahead so and actually
i'm very curious how long does it take
to make a map in battlefield
um somewhere between six and twelve
months based on size complexity
is it a new biome new gameplay
opportunities it's a bunch of time
to pull that off especially our big
player counts it's just a massive
challenge
really balancing everything there so
then that kind of begs the question
how hard is it to run a live service
game a lot harder than we thought
we're still learning how to do it i
think you know it's kind of we get
better every time i hope
and there's a lot of content a lot you
know it's a lot of
testing you know the good part of it is
you can put things out there and try
things and not being afraid of things
failing
you know but that puts a lot more bonus
on the team to create content
that the fans you know like they need to
last an entire three-month season
and have enough content to keep people
coming back and engage and entertained
you'll see yeah we look forward to it
yeah i was gonna say is there any advice
that you'd want to give
christian and his team i'll let chad
answer this one
i you know if i could go back i think
the only advice i'd give myself was to
make sure
that you've got the the pipeline and the
tools and the
and the team ready to start creating
that content because for us
we were all in on launch we launched the
game and then it's like
oh this game got popular we have to do
like a season
season one what are we going to put in
it and we had very little content
ready to go yeah the first couple
seasons were yeah
a lot of work for the team yeah we've
slowed it down now and kind of
balanced you know we want quality of
life for the team too so we kind of
always try to ride that line but the
first couple were
we were also just very used to two year
long or more
light uh development time and then a big
release and it was the same for the
release of apex so we had never done how
do you ship something in
in a month or in three months even so we
just had to completely change the way
that we think about development so oscar
i'm curious after hearing all these
stories
how are you guys preparing for a
battlefield 2040 to use live service
you know of course we've had the
battlefield 4 live service we did
together with christian the team over in
dice la
we'd had you know battlefield 5 just
recently we took star wars battlefront 2
on quite a journey adding new content
and updates involving that game a whole
lot after launch
so we have a couple of tricks up our
sleeve as we get to the
live service for battlefield 2842 and
many of those learnings actually
came from apex legends and all the great
work the respawn team has done with that
game
yeah i mean with this job you kind of
get to learn new things every day we
constantly grow and change and push the
boundaries so
it's one of the most exciting things
about doing this yeah
you also feel like when you release a
game that you work on for that long and
you're done
every you know my experience the team
kind of feels like they wish they could
have done this or that
it's never quite done right sort of the
artist mentality so the nice thing with
live service it's like well it's not
done you can keep
doing you can keep changing you can keep
polishing or doing whatever you want so
there's a benefit you also get that
instant kind of gratification
so normally we spend two to three years
before anyone sees what we're doing
whereas in a live service world we can
create something today and then a few
weeks later it's in the hands of players
when we were doing the community test
environment for bf4
that loop was even shorter we did
something on monday and it was in the
hands of players on tuesday because it
didn't have to be perfect it was a test
environment
and our developers love that that
instant feedback that you get from
something
kind of working that closely with the
community it's very different from the
quiet and secret uh secretive for two
years and then we launch it
uh seems like you guys have a lot of fun
with it which is really great
this is my favorite part
exciting it's time we jump to the part
that everyone has been waiting for
what does the future of fps games look
like to you vince because you have the
most history with fps games we'll start
with you what does the future look like
apex versus battlefield i love it
deathmatch we're gonna bring it on
um i don't know i think the you know the
best part is we don't really know yet
there's so many things that we
haven't even thought about or put
thought into yet that that it's exciting
and
we get new consoles now so we see the
you know the power that we haven't even
really started to unlock yet so that'll
get better and better
yeah how about you chad um the other
thing that excites me
is there's a whole new generation of
gamers and we're up here talking about
you know games we've played in the past
and there's people who have never even
heard of them or never had the chance to
experience them
so i think there's a lot of gameplay
experiences that you can pay homage to
or something or or experiences you can
you can bring right um respawn just just
made a world war two game
for instance and i grew up on a world
war ii game that vince made ironically
um and i think a lot of people
experienced it for the first time and
learned something about world war ii
and um so just opportunities like that
there's a whole new generation of gamers
and
so that's exciting christian it feels
like there's so much more we
could do and should do on the kind of
social side of our games
if you look at a traditional sport you
could kind of i know you could go
outside and just kick a ball or throw a
ball
and you can watch it on tv you can go to
a stadium and watch it
and you can participate in fantasy
versions of it and it's like it becomes
more than just that actual game
which i feel like we're only at the
beginning of that where we can turn it
into more of a social thing where you
you know you hang out in this world in
these worlds that we create not just to
compete
but also just to be there with your your
friends i think there's a ton
of ton of exciting potential there yeah
oscar i'm very curious as to what your
answer is you know cloud computing has
really changed a bunch of other
industries and gaming kind of barely
touched on it so if you think about a
game like battlefield we have things
like ai in the game now destruction
actually procedural level creation and
the next gen consoles there are
of course super powerful but if we move
much of that logic out to the cloud
which is kind of servers and other
language
we can do some really high scale
computing that we haven't been able to
do
in the past destruction visual fidelity
uh and i think it's
just a couple of years away and then
you'll see some pretty cool shooter
games out there i'd imagine but we'll
see
soon trademark battlefield 2042 being
one of them
no comments oh okay
so chad what should we expect from ea
play live on july 22nd
yeah so our next season is rapidly
approaching so we're going to be
unveiling some new information around
our upcoming season
including some information about our
next legend
he is very interesting and unique in
many ways
and i think players will be really
excited to learn about him i'm very
excited to learn and i'm assuming you
can't
hear more about that but i'm so excited
so oscar what's your fans expect
from battlefield 2042 at ea play live on
july 22nd
so i think it's that mode that was on
the whiteboard for many decades and many
years and never kind of happened and now
chris and his team and they have been
you know orchestrating and building it
so christian yeah i mean
it's super exciting and of course a bit
nerve-wracking kind of showing something
for the first time but hoping that the
the players the community will uh will
really embrace and like what we're going
to show them on
uh july 22nd yeah i think they will
christian that's cool
it's really exciting it's cool it's
really cool it is the passion from the
team comes through so you know
every time they show it off it's it's
amazing yeah christian the team actually
showed
lars mr battlefield gustavsson uh that
experience just a few weeks ago
uh and you know lars as you might know
has been with the franchise for the two
decades that existed i think it was
jumping around
on the zoom chair really really happy
with what we saw and i think that's a
great testament to what to expect in
at the year played live so get a sturdy
chair ready to watch it
well thank you guys so much for joining
us here thank you for having me
it was so great to hear everyone's
experiences and i'll let you guys get
back to your game development i'm so
excited to see what you guys have in
store for us
so thank you for joining thank you thank
you thank you thank you for joining us
for this first spotlight
more from the ea play live spotlight
series coming soon
follow at ea on twitter or go to ea.com
for the latest updates
also remember ea play live is july 22nd
and you don't want to miss that
i'm stella chung from ign and this was a
ton of fun
thanks everyone for joining and i'll see
you on the battlefield
the world of random bends with the role
of
one dice this is the story of a magical
kingdom
you're listening to ko city pirate radio
welcome all you new brawlers out there
almost forgot they used to be humans
why'd you look like a blob of play
wanna change back what then you need to
fix your relationship
i got this
that's just me but get yourself a crew
you're not feeling it no okay
[Music]
they should be scared of us
hi i am todd martins a gaming journalist
for the los angeles times and welcome to
the ea spotlight series
this is the second panel in which ea is
connecting you
with the games you love and the people
who make them leading up to ea play on
july 22nd ea invited me to chat with a
number of their independent studios that
are under the ea originals banner
i was happy to do this a lot of the
games in independent space are some of
my
favorite games they are games that tend
to innovate both
technologically and on the storytelling
front ea originals was founded in 2015
with the
mission statement to find cultivate
build successful partnerships with some
of the world's leading independent
studios
the first game under the ea regionals
banner i believe was unravel from
coldwood studios as one of my favorite
games of that year
a number of these games have been
recognized by the baftas and other
industry organizations
so with that let's dig into the panel
and
meet some of the most thoughtful voices
in the independent gaming space today
who are working on projects under the ea
originals banner
thank you everyone for joining us i'm
super excited to talk to all of you i
think we've got kind of a cool
range of voices a different sort of some
different ideas
i just figured we'd do a real quick
intro of just
say your name and uh give a quick
thought of your sort of non-game
background
as well and then just real quickly say
the first game you ever fell
in love with so uh joseph i'll throw it
over to you
yes my name is joseph harris and i'm the
creative
uh director and a founder at hazelite
pretty much
i have actually a background in films
i've done
five or six fishing movies i've been
working with movies pretty much for 10
years
and started making games for 10 years
ago
and my first game i fell in love with
have to be super mario bruce
one even if i played actually started
playing earlier with the atari one
uh well it's a classic and probably one
of the greatest first levels of all time
um olav uh let's hear a little bit uh
from you
and uh over at zoink and some of the
maybe non-game stuff you've
dabbled in uh yeah hi i'm ula vriad malm
and i'm the creative director and the
writer on lost in random
and well my first big
love within video games was baldur's
gate with its huge story
and the possibility of creating your own
story in in that
world and i think i learned english
playing that game too
so and originally i'm a comic artist and
a storyboarder when i started working
with games
that's how i got my foot in there with
drawing my ideas explaining quickly with
with
fast drawings so let's jump over to uh
our
team from silver rain studios uh so
there's a new studio and while we're not
here to necessarily talk about the game
you guys have um abu sort of talk a
little bit about uh
your background and um starting uh this
studio
yeah hi um my name is abubakar salim
um the creative director of our
undisclosed game
at silver ring games originally actor um
also done producing as well within the
film industry and the tv industry
um but yeah decided to get into games
because i mean i love games
one game that i fell in love with the
sonic the hedgehog on the sega that's a
pretty slick game
hi i'm melissa phillips i'm head of
studio at silver rain games
a studio that started we launched in
march 2020 last year
i have backgrounds in both music and
psychology i've got degrees in those
of which i weirdly use none of them
but all of them every single day in my
job
and first game that i really loved and
brought me into games was probably oh
either theme hospital or populist at the
beginning
awesome and guha uh congrats on the
launch of uh knockout city uh pretty
recently this year
so uh you have a pretty wide-ranging
background as well
um i think a lot of people know some of
your background in the tech side of
games but
uh yeah just give us a quick sort of
intro on
you know your world and your expertise
and the first game you fell in love with
uh thank you todd
it's funny if i talk about my non-games
background it's really going to very
early childhood you know karthik my
brother and i started
our first game company vicarious visions
when we were in high school i was 14 and
he was 15 and basically
that was all about learning how to make
a video game and we it's um
you know while we played many video
games uh the actual process of peeling
back how you construct
it every aspect of the creative process
playing all the roles
when there are no instruction books on
how to do it that was just so
fascinating and continues to drive us
and so with vellum studios our mission
is really to find those new types of
interactivity
that the people that are really
unexpected people really wonder where
they come from and you really need to
get your hands on them
uh to be able to understand that now
back in the day what really got me
interested
was a game called starfly 2. actually i
played star flight 1 after 2
it was a pc game uh ms-dos
at the time but it just showed with even
limited technology
you really open the imagination and make
non-linear narrative where you really
put the
player as the hero and as the center of
an adventure
in the center of progression and that
unlocks so much for us
so i don't want to put the uh the new
studio on the spot
but um i guess i'm going to do that a
little bit um abu
just talk a little bit about you know
you said you've loved games but your
decision to
you know really want to express that
love by starting a studio
um you know the journey from starting
that studio to working with ea originals
um and we'll start there yeah no i think
look i mean i i think there's a lot of
um
power in storytelling in games because i
feel like
you've got the audience playing it and
interacting with the characters on the
screen
or you know really kind of shaping the
story that's going on or you get them
in that journey they're they're in their
shoes the way i kind of see it is like
i'm a storyteller by heart right
so it's just another way or another
voice or another
platform to tell those stories on
it's it's a great journey because we're
just all a bunch of kids wanting to
play storytellers right and um yeah
that's what it is
it's funny isn't it we have between us
we've got
a number of years in the games industry
um and we
knew a lot about playing games and how
games were made and the people behind
them
but actually being on the other side now
it's been a whole
learning experience the last year has
been a baptism of fire i guess
as we uh make mistakes but we we learn
from them
and i think that's what's really lovely
about the studio with silver rain is
that
we really value the team that we have
it's an incredible team
uh just over 30 people now um and still
growing
we've always got jobs on the website if
anyone wants to check that out starting
big man 30 people already
damn i remember you that's one of our
learnings jason
i remember when i did brothers we were
like uh we were ten people not eight or
nine people you start big
now i just want to add something to that
because i have a bit kind of the same
background from a movie i just want to
make something clear to add a little bit
what you were talking about
for me these two are two entirely
different mediums it's
very important to remember that because
uh one is interactive and one is passive
because one thing i've learned is that
games are not movies and i think
sometimes the opposite
when you when you like uh want to make a
game that's closer to a movie there are
two entirely different
uh mediums you could get inspired from
each other but the way for instance to
write a book or to write a script
a screenplay are two entirely different
ways of writing stuff
and this is what we need to do for for
again as well so i'm a super optimist
in impactful stories and uh i mean an
emotional impacts on
on people in the future well we're just
there we're just like scratching the
surface
you know uh we had a dark period in
games and it occurred between like 2000
approximately in 2010
but there was a notion among companies
that you would see the film
and then play the game as if the
interactivity would be the same as a
linear medium and
you try to capture empathy like
affection
and love and drama and tension between a
boy and a girl
but with mechanics like shooting and
action
and there would be a total mismatch and
this is sort of the big downfall of
narrative
experiences of the past it makes a lot
of sense also to tell to tell the story
in video games because you're always
following like the interactivity you're
always looking at the step-by-step
experience of the player and like
really immersing yourself in what will
they actually experience what will they
see
and and what will they feel and and for
me that makes so much
sense to tell a story in video games
because um
yeah you're you're really putting
yourself in a situation in a different
way i think and
and it's helped me a lot to to learn
about writing scripts as well like
longer scripts because you have to fill
in the in the details you can't
leave anything to the imagination uh
until
until it's in the player's hands yeah
why'd you look like a blob of play
wanna change back then you need to fix
your relationship
you know um it takes two uh joseph is a
really fascinating game to me
um it deals with a lot of grown-up
topics yet at times it feels very silly
very wacky
and at times the gameplay almost feels
like a metaphor of this couple's
relationship
so i just talk about you know sort of
the challenge of telling what is
you know what on the surface is a very
sort of you know classic story about a
couple
um but then making that come through
very via the actions you're taking in
the game yeah for sure i mean that's
what we at hayslight are focusing a lot
on like trying to use the mechanics as
part of the storytelling
you don't want to end up in a situation
where you play a game
i mean you could play some games
sometimes we're almost waiting for the
next cutscene so the idea is to use it
the mechanics as part of the story i
think it's a little bit underused in
gaming now and i think we can use it way
more often i mean it takes two you have
many situations
sometimes we use it in a metaphorical
way for
there's a level where the characters are
are working on their attraction as
couples and then we we
give them magnets just kind of a as a
metaphoric uh way for them to
both play that and have it in the story
and but also it could be that you know
whatever they meet if they meet uh
like a hammer from a toolbox that they
own or something you're actually playing
so you're playing what you're seeing and
immediately you use the mechanics as
part of the story time you could also
use the mechanics
in a sense to convince uh an emotion for
the player i mean for instance
the first game i did brothers you i mean
i'm gonna spoil it a little bit if if
someone haven't played it but in the end
you're actually
literally like a playing uh like like
burying your big big brother that dies
in the end a little bit so
it's almost and i would say the opening
of last of us where you carry your girl
and runs with her like everything like
you're using the mechanic to to to push
your storytelling and that is a bit
underused sometimes and i think we can
push that even more and that's what
we are hazel i want to keep pushing
the world of random bends with the role
of
one dice olaf um lost in random looks uh
beautiful thank you curious to hear
you talk a little bit about and let sort
of you know people watching know sort of
about
the tone of that game you know the big
picture sort of tone of that game
but also how that sort of pairs
with you know the gameplay and you know
the quote-unquote randomness that you
guys are trying to
sort of come about in how we play that
game yeah in in
lostin random so it's it's a dark fairy
tale it's an action adventure and you
play as this girl
who grows up in in this uh there are
three wards
in the land of random one word for each
side of a six-sided dice
and this dice belong to an evil queen of
course
and she she rules she creates this weird
systems uh to keep these places in check
and so every world has its own theme
when we first started with the project
we wanted to do something darker so a
fairy tale
that was a little bit darker than the
rest of the stuff we'd already made and
um we tried out
drawing all these different characters
and concepts and but it wasn't until
this painting of
of a dice and her girl appeared that we
knew that
there is something to explore the
concept of a living dice as a companion
of
of the protagonist was attractive to us
another scary thing was what would the
gameplay be like what is too random and
what is just random enough everything
revolves around the dice and grows out
of this dice
the theme and the gameplay so it's been
a great
uh concept very natural to like
everything's grown very natural out of
it
and it's so important to to like if you
haven't have an idea that is weird and
you're uncertain of it at first and it
hasn't been done before you don't have a
reference game
you need people you need to ask people
for a bit of faith to stick with the
idea and just stay with it and okay
we're not sure what what it will be and
but it's important to let yourself to be
i don't know let's not know together for
a while and explore this
uh weird idea and see where it goes i
was just going to add in actually
everything that everybody said is is
just lovely and it's exactly why i love
working in games
and what makes the games industry really
special uh
my fear and actually something to
perhaps pose back to the group is that
i always worry about whether we can hold
on to this authenticity
as a as an industry uh because the more
interested
that business and other industries
become in us
uh the more at risk we are of losing
that authenticity i think we're having a
sort of golden age at the moment where
this freedom is allowed and
people like myself can start to see
themselves coming through in these
stories
and i i hope that we can keep that alive
and keep that going and that that
authenticity isn't lost
um or merged into other industries
you know i think uh that's exactly why
we're in these studios because
that authenticity is worth the struggle
it's worth fighting for
and it takes an independent mindset
to really push the boundaries uh to be
able to take the risk
to come out of a typical business model
or a typical franchise stream to create
a unique emotional experience for
players and we have we've made active
choices to have that flexibility
and it comes along with it some kind of
burden as well it's not as predictable
it's not as bankable uh it's uh
um you know you know a lot of the risks
meet with failure
and that has to be a learning experience
and that sounds a little trite
but every indie game cycle involves that
i wouldn't
be too worried actually to have i think
if you have a uh
when you have a strong vision what you
believe in i think actually it's the
opposite the other industries around us
i mean if you look at the movies if
we're talking about that
they will soon realize how great
storytelling is in gaming and
actually are realizing that sometimes if
that's yeah
don't worry there's nothing to fear here
there will come i know the movie
business they will come crawling and
understand how beautiful gaming is
now at the end of the day it's all about
like uh you know
impacting and touching people's hearts
here
guha i wanted to sort of bring it up
with you with uh knockout city because
when people talk about that game that
game isn't necessarily a quote-unquote a
narrative game
it is a a sport you know dodgeball
inspired
um you know but at the same time when i
played that game the first thing that
struck me
was the emotion of that game um like the
tone of that game the way it looked the
way it felt
it was very bright it was extending a
hand to the player it felt very
welcoming
um you know but and we don't necessarily
put that up front when we talk about
games we talk about it as
as a dodgeball as a mechanic as a you do
this you fight this you xyz
we don't necessarily talk about the
emotion you know it's a great uh
great point and it's actually one of the
ways that we center uh discovery of
ellen studios which is
when we create um some something that
feels like the core
of something new a game worth making
we try to ask the question how do you
feel and when we found this kind of
throwing and catching you know just
imagine you know when we were playing
throwing and catching you know some of
us do
i do it all the time with my children
for example but you know through
childhood it's one of the universal
narratives
when you do throwing and catching and
special things with it in all sports
it makes you feel energetic it energizes
you it's a joy when you catch the tough
pass
and so we said okay this is the start of
something joyful competition
we don't see that in games that much
let's build on that and then the world
gives us the grounding knockout city we
invented it as a place to say
how do we experience this joyful
competition a world that's sort of
the way we imagine it should be
inclusive
welcoming uh everything is settled with
epic dodgeball battles
that make it so even if you're outgunned
and outnumbered
with your skill you can actually make a
difference
but then even if you get defeated you're
ready to get back into it
because you feel like you weren't beaten
you feel like you're ready to be back in
the competition
so we start with that emotional profile
all the decisions
from a design standpoint from a world
building standpoint
from a music design standpoint uh come
from that
we even have some backstory to make sure
that the
and we don't explicitly do it we don't
use narrative techniques but it's in the
world
and it's in the vo uh it's to be able to
make people feel like they're grounded
in this
and they can be part of that experience
so we start with mechanics at a core
that feel novel
interesting compelling but really
they're only successful if they elicit
uh some kind of novel emotional response
that says i'm here to play
with my friends and feel something
different so we use different techniques
and narrative
to be able to achieve that and abu
i was kind of curious to hear your
thoughts a little bit um
just we've talked to you in the last few
minutes about some like high-level
topics about
emotion in games and marrying uh
gameplay and story
um and just sort of coming at this from
a new studio i know we're all curious to
hear what you're working on when you're
ready to
talk about it but what would you sort of
say like
what would be maybe like a thesis for
the studio in terms of
where you guys want to put a focus yeah
i mean look it does start with story
right and it starts
with with it starts there but it's
quickly followed by
again the medium in which you're telling
it which is interactivity
i think you know for us as well it's
we're always we're always asking
about that players journey about that
players experience and that's why
it's funny whenever i whenever we talk
about the idea of like you know emotion
and games and stuff
like that like i i don't think that
that's not the aim man like the aim is
to just
is to deliver a brilliant experience
like you don't go to the theater to go
and
you know watch a play which is supposed
to be sad oh you got watch a good play
if it's sad and it's happy that's
fantastic and um
and it's it look in it's it's a it's
tough man like
making games isn't easy it's it's it's a
hard
hard process but that's what's so
brilliant and beautiful about it because
i
i truly believe that through the through
the difficulty of finding something and
hitting it right
you end up basically sharing that
difficulty and
that hard you know that hard journey
with the person playing it they feel
that
and they are able to experience that
with you i was just going to add in as
well
and here's the kicker like ideas are
cheap everybody has ideas
my mom has ideas my dog has ideas i have
ideas you know we are a team
where everybody has the capability of
being creative in some way
the hard part i think of game making is
how do we
choose which ideas we take forward out
of this
mad pool of ideas that we have
and i think the craft comes from being
able to
select the best sometimes just the most
feasible ideas not even the best we
sometimes have to
kill some fantastic ideas but
the game making process is about how do
we prioritize what goes forwards what
feels good
um and the craft comes from actually
making those ideas and
and testing them and iterating on them
and making sure that all of that comes
together to create the game
when i was playing it takes two i went
into that game
you know the pandemic was still very
much a mystery here in america at that
time
and then there was the other idea of
like i was also going through a
relationship that was falling apart
so i didn't necessarily i was nervous
about playing
it takes two because i was like do i
want to play a game about a divorce um
at the same time like that game is so
silly and fun and inventive like i never
once felt necessarily quote unquote sad
i just felt
exuberance at like learning about these
characters
someone asked me like uh is this kind of
a relation
you know shift uh to help you it's kind
of kind of a therapy session or
something
the funny part is that we saw already in
the testing already when playing the
game that
if you're in a relationship that wasn't
so good it was quite clear actually
because you really had to you know it's
almost like the experience or in the
couch that's almost also how we design
the game so
if you if you're playing this with your
partner and your communication is not
right
then you're not going to be able to play
the game that good so not only would you
will the game be you know not have the
same fluidness in the game you will also
may say something about your own
relationship that something is not
working
and from that perspective we're seeing i
mean reactions today
i don't know how accurate or true they
are of people actually
you know asking each other to get
married after the game and stuff like
that
and that's quite cool actually if it's
true i don't know but that's how they
write to us
i have to accept that it is a true thing
but it's a good way to get to know like
where you are at in your relationship
because obviously communication is key
i mean yes it takes two it takes you to
communicate as well guha i wanted to
sort of transition a little bit
and hear your thoughts on with sort of a
game like knockout city which is going
to be an ongoing game and it's going to
evolve
you know you and the team are maybe
thinking about adding some story
but keeping that sort of lively and
keeping that constantly sort of fresh
um and and the way you know game studio
can experiment
with a live service game in in ways that
you know we don't get in other
other mediums you know i'm todd the um
mindset for us always was let's get the
game out
and then see how the community responds
and embraces it and then evolve it with
a community
and so from the very early onset it was
designed as a sort of live service
product which
finds an audience and then follows the
audience and evolves it and continues to
surprise
so we have a slew of content that's
actually in production that will be
available
and the idea is surprise them
with new things that can change up the
play now we'll have evolution of the
hideout
which is your interactive social lobby
where you team up with friends
before you get into a game instead of
waiting at a menu to be able to find out
if they show up
and you know that kind of thing and so
it was really interesting you know the
early prototypes of knockout cities
started
um in 2017 so a little over four years
before it was launched
that's a long longish cycle for a game
but it feels like we're
still at the starting uh line you know
the launch is the start
you know there's this conversation
always in pop culture amongst fans and
amongst creators that it's like
everything has to be based on ip um and
in the independent game world
this is where all of like originality is
um you know and i was kind of curious
olaf to hear
you know you talk a little bit about the
studio and deciding
on lost and random and like what was the
sense of
you know because as melissa was saying
earlier like everybody has ideas
so what was the sense of like this is
something that we can experiment with
both as a studio that we can experiment
with
is artists but something we feel good
about you know committing
you know x amount of years of our lives
to
me personally of course there's great
value in looking at the market and what
people are playing right now but people
won't be playing what they are now
in a couple of years so why not just go
with what's fun
and weird uh in in the moment it's it's
a
it's a very art driven studio always has
been zoink
uh driven by klaus lingalad who's now
the head of the development and he's
usually the guy like well we're sweating
and finishing the previous game he's
like
guys what do you think about a giant
ghost in vr and we're like yeah we got
to finish this thing first but sounds
great give us some time and and digest
it abu already said also we're all
just kids playing like like oh then this
guy comes and he he fights this guy and
they're they're brothers actually and
why
like that kind of energy you want to
bring to to creating video games i think
so yeah just just uh go with that
creative
joy and and for us it started out with
wanting to try out something darker like
i already said than our
longing for a fantasy and a saga and you
know we looked at grim fairy tales and
over the garden wall and stuff like that
and even if the idea
at first makes everyone go ah really
hmm okay dice with legs and arms and
okay let's taste it for a bit and and
like don't be afraid of the can of worms
yeah i guess it's the message yeah just
wanted to say like
that is actually a perfect um sort of
analogy in a way of what
the originals like team do in regards of
like
they're not afraid to take a risk like
you can you will come in with a crazy
idea and you'll come in with something
quite quite out there something that's
not really necessarily been seen or
sounds
dangerous or sounds hard and they will
be like you know what
go for it they give you that space and
room to play which is so
so beautiful and rare to see in
in a lot of spaces in the arts like like
look i'm i'm doing a show at the moment
out here
called raised by wolves and the first
two episodes of the season
thanks it was great the first
thank you well no but like look the
first two episodes right
were directed by ridley scott and it's
it's terrifying
right it's one of those things where
it's like you you're
you're going head-to-head with this
goliath right but
the beauty of what he was able to
capture on set
was he allowed you room to play he
allowed your room to be bold he allowed
you room to just
explore which is so rare sometimes i
think every publisher should do this
actually focus on creative crazy games
that does something very different but
doesn't have the major financial risk
because i understand like you want to
put a hundred million dollars something
that's crazy risky however though
those smaller games are crazy and more
creative adventure
you can actually see stuff functioning
and working and then you can actually
inspire the triple a also as well
you know joseph i want to um yeah look
at that and say you know
it's not just about inspiring triple a
it's about saying
you know all new novel concepts can
start small
you know it's the kind of the simple as
a hard concept hey
you know when we wrote our if you write
the concept for knockout city on a piece
of paper people will be like
i'm going to play this action game with
dodge balls uh give me a gun i think i
know how to do that
um and so that's typically the response
for that but the concept itself could be
proven out at a small scale
and the concept itself can grow and it
can be grown
by the same by you joseph in your
context by us
from a knockout city standpoint but it's
the ability to recognize that something
special
both the developer recognizes but then
also you know the label should recognize
as well
and believe in one of the things that
was most impressive to us was that
um after we had found this core and
you know we thought hey this this is a
good game i'm feeling what i need to
feel
with this thing we chopped it around and
there's something unique about the
originals team in ea everybody played
everybody all the way to the executive
team at eight played before we said huh
that's the right partner for us
because they could understand that
vision they could see it and they said
okay we're ready to take a risk not a
huge risk
but we're ready to take a risk and
serious sequential bets because this
game
needs to come out well in knockout city
was also kind of a risk for the studio
as well like you guys had to create
uh pretty much a new a new game engine
for this project
yeah i mean there was uh nothing like it
before and there's a good reason
it's really hard to do a mechanic that's
purely based on
throwing and catching essentially
physics-based gameplay in a competitive
setting
where there are many physics objects
that player him or herself could be
themselves become the ball uh that
there's a ever-changing map landscape
with dynamic maps
and fundamentally relies on the
interactivity between the team
throwing cat pat passing catching when
you have a player on the east and west
coast or
east coast and then in europe playing
together or playing against each other
it's an incredibly hard problem to solve
and we couldn't find conventional
approaches to do it
so we had to invent the computer
language to be able to
allow us to do reversible computation at
scale and that's pretty much how we
approach problem solving here of l and
it's sort of like
you know if this game needs to be made
we're going to figure out how to do it
i just want to add on even if we're
working with
unreal you know but let me tell you this
the amount of stuff we added on to make
an
online game also function in split
screen with so much variety in game
mechanics it's
absolute madness uh actually i know that
we made more tools that unreal are using
from us
than we are using from them so in a
sense we created our own
i mean it's a huge challenge to create
an online game i mean not not
i mean especially in split screen where
you see the lag and everything so
there's
i think i think whoever has an engine
you need to do a lot of add-ons that
fits your vision and game
like you're saying yeah i know i was
curious joseph
if being an indie studio if you felt
that that made that task
of having to sort of invent those tools
even using a popular game engine and
just being independent if that made it
you know easier for you guys like as a
studio to sort of
shift directions at whims or because it
seems like it is a very big of a mission
statement for your studio to
do sort of co-op sort of games i
wouldn't call
us in the india right now i would say we
are a bit we are more a triple
i as they say today not not just a
regular indie
so we have more knowledge our developers
are more
like you know a more kick-ass they know
more how to do stuff we know more how to
solve stuff we've done it before
so we have the tools to do it uh way
better than before but
but of course it's always a risk
especially the games we do because every
game we do
is something totally different obviously
you have co-op and story that is common
to what we do
but the world the characters the
gameplay everything is
totally different in the next game let
me tell you it will blow people's mind
actually
i'm ready to hear about it
are you really are you ready can you
handle it that's what i'm telling you
man
next game will be like what the these
guys have really lost their minds
i mean totally in a good way bring it on
you know we touch on a lot of different
topics uh today
and you know just on the subject of
being an independent studio and the ways
an independent studio can innovate
in maybe ways other studios can't
just kind of wanted like a real quick
sort of hit from each one of you
on your studios and like where you want
to go in the future
when it comes to innovation so at
hazelite
what we want to push all the time is
combining the story in the gameplay we
push that a lot using the mechanics more
and more to try to tell the story
use the mechanics to reflect what goes
on the story create unique cool
experience that players haven't played
before
now is the time to make something
totally great and unique it's harder in
a movie today because
it's been going on for longer so in a
sense it's a good time to make something
great
you know from valence studios it's you
know our games have come to be
um really sort of playing is believing
but playing as believing
is really at the heart of creating
something new an experience that people
really think is novel i haven't seen
something like this before
and that's what we want to keep doing at
sewing i feel like we're always looking
for new ways of delivering story and
dialogue and because it's it's such a
diverse
industry with so many different people
and backgrounds and
and ways of thinking and working from
programmers to artists
so i think i mean that's such a huge fun
inspiring part and why i love working
with games
i was going to say we are so young as a
studio
that i think we're incredibly grateful
for the fact that we get to do
something that we really love i don't
think either of us realized how much we
were going to love
working on this game and part of that is
the unknown um to have come as far as we
have in
one year i just i'm so excited to see
where it goes yeah i feel like we do
have we do have a voice
and we're still finding our voice and
and and we're
we're growing not only as a studio and
evolving at such a rapid pace like
pace but we're having fun while doing it
as well and i think it's about
sharing that fun and you know sharing
sharing our experience
our highs and lows and just being open
because again that's
you know that's also part of it right
it's about being open about sharing
thank you all for letting me pester you
with so many questions and playing along
and
i really appreciate it everyone's time
thank you thank you all so much thank
you
cool thanks guys thank you thank you so
much great to be here with
all of you thank you so that was all
very thoughtful
and uh very inspirational at times uh
thank you for joining us
more from the ea play live spotlight
series will be coming soon
follow at ea on twitter or go to ea.com
for the latest updates on these games
and everything else from the studio
also remember that ea play live is on
july 22nd
and if you've watched this far you
definitely don't want to miss that
because there will be some exciting news
from lost and random
i'm todd martens from the los angeles
times thank you for joining us
[Music]
me
welcome to the third episode of ea
spotlight series that connects you to
the games you love and the people who
make them
i'm nick mazesco and today we are
talking all about madden nfl 22
franchise and the exciting reveal
of scouting i've been waiting for this
day all week long please join me in
welcoming executive producer sean grady
franchise producer tom lichke
and franchise designer moonlight swami
you might know him as
andre weingarten thank you so much for
taking some time out of today i'm
excited
to talk about madden nfl 22 but before
we start
let's get a look at the game that's
coming out madden nfl 22.
you're gonna see a lot of teams try and
restart the clock with their
quarterbacks what happens if they are
who's most likely to return to the super
bowl
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
don't want to catch
[Music]
accepted
to this denver crowd making it tough on
the kansas city offense
making it hard to hear yourself think in
the holes he's saying the same thing he
can't hear anything
[Music]
[Applause]
he just gets this way deep seven seconds
six seconds
[Music]
now i'm very excited to talk more about
franchise learn a little bit more about
this scouting
as a complete and total franchise nerd
this is probably my greatest day of the
year so
you know the viewers are here to learn
about scouting i know everybody out
there wants to hear about it but
before we get there let's take a step
back for a second let's let's go to
madden 21
you know you guys just delivered a third
and final huge update
you know you added some features to
franchise mode this is a big year tell
me how you're feeling shawn about how
madden 21 went
overall in retrospect yeah i'm feeling
really good it's been a lot of work
a lot of feedback from the community a
lot of work from our team and these guys
over here
at the start of the year when we kicked
off matt 21 we got a lot of
feedback from the franchise community
that they were looking for more they
wanted more from their mode
so what we tried to establish with them
is that we hear you we're listening
and because our game is a live service
as we've said many times over the course
of this year that we can deliver more
features to you guys so as you said we
we put a road member out there for three
title updates we delivered some of the
top requests uh that our fans were
asking for like
x factor customization a playoff bracket
some commissioner tools on and on we can
talk about some others as well uh and as
we arrive at the end of the year yeah i
think we're all really proud of what we
were able to give to the the community
i got to tell you every multi-user
franchise i saw commissioner tools and
we're like
yes more please thank you i feel like
madden's so unique because not only do
you have
all these different modes from franchise
to ultimate team to you know superstar
ko but
then you have the different ways to play
inside those modes and is that a
constant discussion of the guys who just
want to go and win super bowls the guys
like me who want to
find the right number of where do i set
the parking so that people tune in
and give me some more money like how do
you balance that sort of development
when we build something and it happens
all the time like one of the features
this year
um we redid the hub for franchise for
22.
uh but we got to make sure that works
really well if you're coming at it
player centric or owner-centric or coach
centric and there's just all these
little cases
uh that we have to figure out in testing
and playing it and bringing in the right
people making sure we're getting that
coverage
and sometimes you'll do stuff that well
this is just straight up
a coach mode or an owner mode thing so
then you have to talk about
all right do we want to do that or is
that do we do something that applies to
everybody i'm curious when we when we're
going into 22 we talk about the changes
of
uh of franchise mode going into 22 and
at 21. were there any changes that had
to be made
in the team itself in terms of you know
just structure
as you moved into madden 22 to tackle
franchise mode i would say there's
things that had to be made but in the
case of franchise
we wanted to bolster the team we want to
strengthen it with with more of our
talent across madden we wanted to invest
more in
a number of new features which means we
had to put more people onto franchise
which we absolutely did this year
and then we just made sure that we had
the people that were most passionate
about the mode
working in it so that uh the people that
are playing it are the people that are
building it and that's that's kind of
where we end up
uh yeah so the team in some ways built
itself like the the franchise junkies if
you will kind of
re-emerged and i'm not going to look at
him straight up
but
that's gotta be pretty cool for you guys
to work on a mode that's been across so
many different games it's not an
a new mode like the yard or ko which are
cool but french has been in madden for
so long
oh absolutely i mean when i started
playing back in around 2002 i was
seven years old and what did i play it
was only franchise i mean i play some
play now you know run around with
michael vick for
you know days on worst kind of person
everybody
hey i'm sorry i'm so sorry to everybody
out there
but i mean that's what i did and even if
i didn't know exactly what i was
building what i was building as a team
i knew i was having fun and i was
building a team so
as i started getting older and started
investing myself more in the features
i really grew to appreciate what was
there so now
looking back on it it's a perspective of
yes
whether i was eight years old and i
enjoyed it or i'm now 25 and i enjoy it
there are features that are relevant to
both ages
that need to be represented because you
want someone who
really doesn't know exactly what they're
doing to still be able to enjoy
themselves but you also want to give
that depth to the people who really want
to dive in can i just say to all the
seven-year-olds out there watching right
now
there is a future there is a future in
madden if you're playing the game right
now
andre is the example come work for us
one day keep playing the game
as somebody who works in the gaming
industry i can tell my parents take that
like video games
was what i was supposed to do exactly i
think that's the cool thing also about
franchise mode is that
there's so much depth in it for for the
nerds like me that want to adjust prices
and deal with coaching staffs but it's
also the easiest to sort of explain to
anybody
listen you're taking a team go out and
win a super bowl build that team do
whatever you want to do and
but i'm curious and i guess sean
probably can answer this the best
it feels monumental from the outside i'm
sitting there going how do you even
tackle that was that a challenge at
something
so broad as franchise mode i actually
don't think it is because there's so
many good ideas out there
it's really a matter of then okay
prioritizing it and coming up with a
good design that pays that thing off
so you know we'll talk a bit about staff
management but uh you can say you're
going to do that how do you build it how
do you make it fun how do you gamify it
and make it interesting
that's the hard part but the ideas of
what you want to go to attack and the
prioritization on the roadmap i think is
a little bit
actually more straightforward there's
plenty of uh opinions on the internet
for sure
breaking news i should find out what
this internet thing is plenty plenty of
opinions out there and then uh so how do
you
take that and distill it and then how do
you maybe are there some people that can
stand up and represent the community
interest and bring them in and that's we
called the design council
and brought in some you know really key
people who we feel like are a good
representative voice
bring them into the process because we
have all these ideas
and let's go through it and then say how
do we get the best ideas or the right
first ideas so that design console was
part of the approach
that's why we're here today is the like
one of the top things they said made
sense but
it didn't make sense as the first thing
we did so that you know that being
scouting
well you know i'm i'm lucky enough to be
a part of that madden design council and
i've been lucky enough to be involved in
some of these feedback events in the
past and even at the franchise specific
events
like it was a lot of guys who played the
way similarly that i did but
in the design council you got so many
different voices coming in and i felt
like we were involved
way earlier than in past years was that
a concerted effort and how did that help
in the development of madden 22.
part of it was driven by the fact that
we had to get we
we just knew we with the sentiment at
launch and what we felt
we felt it too we needed to get going we
couldn't wait for the next
product to release to make progress um
so that
gave us the need to bring people in
earlier like we were talking about the
what we're releasing now uh back in i
think it was september september october
yeah
end of september october yeah and the
big fundamental difference is when
you're talking about it september you
haven't
built anything yet and so there's all
kinds of opportunities for change
if you're showing people stuff in
february uh it might feel like a long
ways to what the game's released
but we're already at things are pretty
locked down and we're finishing things
and polishing things
that's a that's a big difference between
the two stages of development there's so
many places that feedback come from you
talk about the internet you talk about
the design council
but you also have internal feedback
coming in you also have guys just
streaming on twitch who maybe aren't
typing out a twitter post but are still
giving feedback how do you parse through
all that information and find the
nuggets that then you can take and put
into a road map for a game like madden
22.
i would say there's pockets within the
team that um gravitate to a specific
platform like
i like to watch youtubers so we have a
lot of youtubers you you know who you
are i watch a lot of these guys i listen
i don't comment or anything but i'm kind
of listening to their themes
yeah so you're a lurker i'm allergic to
america yeah yeah there's there's some
uh
guys and gals that are on twitter that
are you know listening to twitter which
i don't go to twitter as much anymore
because twitter's not quite as
constructive as we might want it to be
with ea in the handle
the feedback finds you in a lot of ways
but i find some of the best feedback on
there
personally because i'm i'm able to
engage with those people in conversation
i think that's really why i still
maintain that presence because i can
have a conversation of
you know someone finds a bug or someone
has feedback and i can say well what do
you mean by that
what settings do you have things like
that so being able to have that back and
forth and then relay it
personally i find that incredibly
valuable and it's worth
the mean tweets and things for all of
that feedback i appreciate the fact that
you're still out there
what are you saying thank you for taking
on twitter cheers
[Laughter]
now i mean i've read the deep dives i've
read the blogs you know we've talked
there's so many exciting things to come
out coaching staffs talent trees
scouting which we're going to talk about
don't worry we're going to get there
what do you what feature
what edition are you most excited about
in madden 22 sean we'll start with you
i'm going to take uh game planning as my
favorite at this point because i like to
uh
sorry tom if i took that from you i i
just left right there just because you
did that thanks a lot
one benefit is it's going to allow you
to game plan against a
real world opponent you know like we
know the data for the kansas city chiefs
from tampa bay buccaneers and how they
play and we're going to use next-gen
stats to see what they do
whatever oh did we win a super bowl yeah
i guess so
it hurts yeah uh so i like that
so real world data gives you information
that you can use to say i'm going to try
to shut down
uh you know the deep threat from from
kansas city and then it gives a little
bit of a boost to some of your players
to try to attack that and if that's not
working i can adjust
in half time two things we've never had
before i find that really compelling but
if i'm playing with some friends online
as well as we progress through a couple
of weeks and through a couple of seasons
their data is going to be logged as well
i'm going to know what their strategies
are and i can game plan against that and
that's just
that's just fun you know like and so
swami may be playing a certain way week
to week
he probably is going to anticipate my
game plan for that and maybe he's going
to switch it up that week
there's a little bit of extra element of
strategy in there so that's my number
one
so mine is uh mine's really franchise
staff though the way franchise
has been in the past like where do you
get your power from in franchises
building your roster
so it's kind of there's this one path to
making a stronger franchise
and we're just adding this whole other
parallel path to say
uh i'm gonna go build up my staff and
change how my my franchise plays week to
week based on
this power curve not just my roster yeah
i mean to echo that i think
franchise staff and maybe focusing more
on the talent trees themselves
are really what i think is my favorite
improvement for the simple fact that
you know all those different layers get
kind of that umbrella treatment of
we can really enhance beyond the system
and give you the opportunity to shape
your
your entire franchise differently every
single time
i mean to have over 60 different talents
with all different types of power
to them and then the ultimate talents
really have distinct power that
change the way that your franchise may
function whether it be giving more
focused players i know that's something
that
tying into the weekly strategy three
focus players always kind of felt
restrictive
because i just didn't feel like enough
players were getting the attention that
they needed to become
special so being able to expand that up
to six with the with that talent
i mean that is an entirely different way
to handle your weekly strategy make you
excited
to jump into that so that's your
favorite really it's not scouting
guys we're teasing scouting someone has
to say scouting i mean
we have a whole discussion about
scouting it's really interesting being
in that group because
you know there's something that i might
care about from a multi-user franchise
that somebody who's just a solo player
doing content for example
they've never even like bothered to
think about like commissioner tools i
don't think anybody's in a
in a single player franchise cares about
commissioner tools they are the
commissioner and the only player but at
the end of the day
all the multi-users i know in all the
multi-user franchises were so pumped
when commissioner tools got into the
game
you thought it was christmas day yeah
our philosophy is uh
it's your franchise it's your game you
choose how much of any given thing you
want
or don't want so you can have the
experience you want so
yeah the way that i look at that is
we're building something to enhance your
experience
and i don't want it to become a
detractor for you because
you're locked into one way of playing
that might not mesh with your overall
style you know i know sometimes i have a
league where
i just want to face the computer i just
want to blow them out i just want to
have fun and not worry about
any level of simulation and there's
other leagues where i want a competitive
hardcore experience that is a totally
different environment for me yeah i'm
just looking for a multi-user league
that'll let me win a super bowl that's
all i'm looking for
um as somebody who works in the
competitive sphere i gotta say it's it's
really cool to see
these guys who are playing ultimate team
on the competitive level
they're getting into franchise mode
because they're looking for just
something different outside of the grind
that is
the competitive game and they're loving
starting up these leagues with their
friends and everybody's picking a team
and they're dealing with trades they're
you're seeing different people get into
franchise mode and i didn't realize that
was something that was possible i
thought everybody just played franchise
mode because that's how everyone got
into madden yeah i think
what the biggest gift we can give people
is the ability to walk away with a story
and that's what franchise naturally can
do is you know it's the story of my
league or my team or whatever it is and
regardless of how you play day to day
it's it's always kind of fun
to go and build your story and walk away
with uh what was this version of my
franchise
and that's actually one of the things
we're hoping to continue to to push and
evolve as we build our franchises
if i make the exact same choices from
the beginning
with two leagues hopefully uh
they'll play out differently right
because you know maybe i'll throw
five passes to my third round draft pick
receiver and i'll get us
a season engine event which says okay
now it's about him
it's a breakout moment what do we do and
we start building the franchise that
direction
so more of that in the future is
definitely where we want to go to the
sideline
don't want to catch look at the move by
cook
are you kidding me
i think it's time to get into the
scouting when can we expect to get our
hands on it
all right we're excited to get this in
the hands of our players it's going to
kick off our live service continuous
development for this year for
franchise so it's coming early in the
season we're targeting
this first one for september uh first
big beat
of you know three seemed to be a cadence
that worked for us last year like three
groups of
uh content that we've delivered through
the course of the year so we'll be
looking at that same approach this year
i know i'm excited i wonder who we
should talk to about
scott don't look around staring right at
you andre we're dying
tell us what we can expect uh with uh
the revamp of scouting
all right so that deep sigh really makes
me excited because i know that means
this for a year so i've been waiting a
long time for this
so scouting as a whole is being
revamped obviously you'll still be able
to scout players but the way that we go
about it is entirely different
we're moving away from the scouting
point system where you have
a bucket of points each week and then
you spend it on players
this is more making key decisions
throughout the season
that progress every single player on
your board at different points
so you start things off essentially by
getting a baseline scouting on every
player in the
in your class you know this guy runs
fast he can
move well he's strong and they sounded
like mel keiper right now he's got
quiet hands one of the big goals i had
was
i wanted to add complexity to the
feature but i wanted to remove some of
the tediousness of it
so you don't have to go in every single
week and feel like you're missing
something if you don't
but they're key decision points that
you're going to want to interact with
because that'll shape how your board
basically evaluates itself over the
course of the season
so you'll be able to pick a position per
each of your now
four area scouts and a national scout
rather than just being a scouting
department
you have individual scouts with
strengths and weaknesses so i might have
a guy who
specializes in scouting quarterbacks
yeah and
you're going to send them out the area
scouts to one of four regions on the map
you know some regions have more schools
than others so we kind of cut them off a
little bit at the past
so each region has its merit to send a
quality scout
and you'll be able to assign your scouts
at the start of each season
based on a preliminary big board and the
big board
is changing in itself it's no longer
just
you know here's all the players ranked
we're treating it more as a media big
board
so a player has a few really good games
in a row right
and you see a news blurb pop up that
this player just
you know he's been dominant you're going
to see that he's going to
move up the draft board so the ai itself
is going to
draft players based on the changes in
perception and evaluation of the players
instead of it being that you know you
find this guy in the fifth round
and he's the best player in the class
and he just sits there that's not going
to happen anymore
it's really going to be a lot more that
if you find that player and you really
key in on them
at different scouting events you'll be
able to
get gather a large amount of information
but it comes at a cost and the cost is
awareness
for the media so you send your national
scout and we call it focus scouting
this is one of the biggest milestones in
terms of report completion that you're
going to get
and when you do that the media is going
to be aware that you are attending this
player's game
so if it's a sixth round player and
you're sending your national scout the
guy who you want the best report from
to a sixth round players game for that
guy
they're gonna be like whoa whoa this guy
can't have any secrets is what you're
saying i can't secretly scout anyone
you can scout in secret but you might
have to sacrifice a little bit of
information
right if i'm trying to get that full
completion that's basically me sending
my national scout in the front row and
everyone knows that i'm sitting there
to scout this guy yeah exactly and you
know you'll have private workouts
that you'll be able to do same same
premise where you'll have a few players
that you can bring in for those private
workouts
and that'll give you a big boost in the
report completion
but there's additional layers to it so
that big board ebbs and flows
and there'll be mock drafts well we
right now we have it scheduled for
five mock drafts over the course of the
season so as draft position changes
so does this so if you need to make a
decision on
oh man i'm not gonna be able to get to
pick 16 and they're looking at this
player and this position
i might have to jump them or i have to
change my plans on who i'm looking at
so the entirety is more information
my legit my first thought with this was
in a multi-user league
is it possible for somebody to throw
somebody off their scent to sit there
and go like
i know like for example if i'm the
dolphins and i sort of know where i'm
gonna be and i know
the bengals are right behind me and
they're gonna be drafting and i know
that they're gonna be
you know wanting to jump me if i'm
looking for a quarterback can i start
scouting
offensive lineman to try to throw them
off that oh you don't need to jump me
you're fine
stay there uh theoretically yes thank
you i'm looking to be a real dirk in my
league so i i appreciate that
that's one of those things that we
talked about earlier um building it in a
way that
people who want to go that layer deeper
be a multi-player leagues or whatever
that there's that deeper design there
that's a good
solid approach i think so absolutely and
we've talked with former nfl personnel
former scouts
media members who do scouting all sorts
of different groups of people
about the scouting process and the one
thing that always comes back to me is
the aggregation of information is the
hardest part
of scouting because you can understand
every single layer of a player skill set
but if you don't piece it together
properly to make that full picture
it doesn't matter and that's where a lot
of people get tripped up you can see
this guy's fast or this guy has a big
arm but if you don't understand that
well yeah he has that big arm
and he can throw deep but because he
doesn't have the mental processing
or the awareness for our game's sake
then he's not going to be that guy
that you would expect or that he was in
college so
aggregation is not going to be exact
you might not find their exact true
talent range
and it's a range this year instead of
saying this guy's a first round pick
it'll be you know round one to round two
or
top five you know those blue chip
players those are clear cut
and as you get later in the draft that
range is wider
so we want to give you as much
information as possible without
overwhelming
and i mean i'm overwhelmed right now i'm
not gonna lie
this is this is unbelievable i'm so
excited for this what would you say was
the most
important thing for you to get right
when it came to scouting
obviously the information itself what
what we're giving you and how we're
giving it to you was really important
but the loop of what are the
reveal milestones what are your action
points right when do you need to engage
with this system
and can you engage with it when you
don't need to
so for me i staggered it throughout the
season
because i wanted to make sure that there
was information
relevant for you as a player at each
stage of the season
and then the postseason hits and you can
focus on your playoff games
you don't have to worry about scouting
at all off season comes back around
boom it hits you back up again and
that's when you really start diving in
you get the combine the pro days the
private workouts
so making sure that you have something
to do at all the relevant points
especially when the season lulls
and making sure that it stays out of
your way when it doesn't need to be
there but you can always go in and look
that scouting tab will never disappear
my first one my favorite thing is these
guys work on the game and they are
locked
into this discussion these guys know
about like i'm locked in because i
know these guys are listening on the
edge of their seats
um is there something built into the
game that's going to prevent me from
signing all the best scouts and turning
the cleveland browns into the dynasty
that they truly deserve to be don't tell
me otherwise
i describe it as there are tiers to your
scouting department that you need to
fill
so rather than it being i have a certain
amount of points or i'm just going to
sign all the best scouts
you have let's say three tiers
and that really modifies how much uh
additional bonus you get when scouting a
position of expertise so
it's really not that you're picking the
best scouts you're picking
the scouts that are most logical for you
but they have two positions of expertise
and that's going to be a little bit of a
teaser for something that we're going to
be dropping in the future
but it's going to be there and the
second one is grayed out
you'll be able to access that at some
point post launch
but we're not going to get too much into
that so you're you're picking up there's
ultimate tease right there
something that's coming out something
later of teasing teasing
so but the idea is that that expertise
is really what's driving you
well we know andre he's like me he's
he's a
hardcore franchise player i'm curious
from you guys do you guys feel like
there's something
applicable here in scouting to the
casual fan is this something that's
valuable to somebody just picking up
trying to win a super bowl
so a casual fan when we asked them said
well what do you want to franchise well
i want to win super bowls and so how do
you win super bowls you build your
roster up over years
it's how do you build your roster you
add players scouting needs to be really
powerful
and accessible in terms of i can make my
franchise better each year like we said
earlier you know kind of monitor and see
how
players use it and if we see some of
those casual players going in
then we're doing something right and if
not then we can continue to iterate on
the design we
i think almost kind of designed it for
our core franchise player first because
that's who we're
we're hearing loud and clear from you're
welcome uh but of course we do want
those other casual players that still
want to build a roster in the way that
they want to build it to use it and so
we monitor and you know iterate long
term you know my
my game looping franchise is much more
uh go in make a couple decisions play
the game
um and scouting in the pa right now
feels like well it even warns me like if
i don't go spend those points they're
lost
so i feel like okay i got to do that
even though i
it's a little bit nebulous to me what's
happening i still have to do it or i'm
losing power
and the one thing i don't want to do is
lose power because i feel like i'm just
that much further from one of those
super bowls absolutely and i think
that's one of the other considerations
that we had
where if you choose not to interact with
the system it'll essentially autopilot
for you and it'll treat it like the
computer is doing it rather than costing
you
for not interacting with it what you'll
take a pass on is that granular control
like you'll be
bending your scouting department towards
a certain need if you just like
building a roster and just going through
season after season you can still get
that as long as you spend
just a little bit of time right at the
front right it's not like it's week
three anymore
it is pre-season week one that you're
jumping into scouting for the first time
get it right away as opposed to having
to wait for that yeah and your touch
point literally is assigning which
region
you don't have your scouts will go out
and do their thing immediately you don't
have to pick a single player
all you need to do is evaluate the big
board see a mock draft say where you
want them to go
and then let them go for the entire
preseason you could skip the preseason
and you're not going to miss a thing
yeah i'm just curious like you know
i feel like this is the value of sitting
down with you guys and talking with you
in the spotlight series is being able to
talk with the guys who make the game and
i think
the biggest thing i i think that is
important to convey is why
and i guess my question is why have you
guys made such a focus on servicing
franchise
post launch and making it a live service
you know gamers are 12 month of year
gamers now it's
in the past it would be i'd pick up
madden and play it for a couple months
or on launch and
it's really hardcore you might play it
longer but now it's that's not the
expectation anymore and
and we hold ourselves to a standard of
we want it to be something that
you'll do you know a good chunk of the
year and have it be interesting and
fresh
we've already been doing it for years
inside madden with but it's primarily
been through ultimate team so
really it's laddering franchise up to
that same sort of standard
um knowing that that's not the easiest
thing in the world to do because
ultimate team was built to be good at
that and franchise was built to be good
at
providing a season in a sandbox and it
is a different live service than
ultimate team yeah right ultimate team
you have messaging every week almost
daily so
you know you're going to miss some of
that day-to-day messaging
that i know that some people have been
clamoring for but
that's just kind of the nature of the
mode it is a it is such a large sandbox
that it's just not
as modular on a day-to-day basis but it
can be modular and we're
really emphasizing that on a yearly
basis
ultimate team actually like absorbs
new content and stand-out performances
yeah
and it just gets added into whatever
what you've already built there
franchise is not like that
i already have a story that's in
progress so maybe we would add
a scenario to the season engine that
says you know
uh tom brady suddenly actually is still
good
so you know let's let's not let's not go
outside the realm of reality it pains me
like i didn't know i was walking into
this today right like after watching my
packers
one person here that's really happy
about this i know you know
who designed but but we would bring that
in via
uh additional storytelling add to the
story you already have
an ultimate team that's like oh no
there's just a cool new player that had
a breakout thing and yeah i want to add
that to my sandbox
it's just replacing right yeah which you
can't do
you don't want to overwrite all of
everything you did if we modified tom
brady because he had a great weekend
season
and you're in year you know six and he's
now 55 years old
and he's if i'm the box owner i want tom
brady to be really good like
the only person who wants is the one who
has um that player
um now i i think i can ask this um is
there
is there any anything you can tease
that's coming to franchise
post you can ask
there are things we're thinking about
for sure uh we we put a lot of energy
towards uh resetting the baseline in
terms of the feature set with
uh you know franchise staff and the
weekly strategy where we haven't put
as much energy yet is maybe in terms of
free agents and
things like that so that's an area that
we think about and talk about is
trades and and whatnot is there
something we can do there what is the
relevant information at different points
in the year that we can
raise to you to make you care about not
just your
team but kind of expand you out of that
that bubble
that is kind of described of your
team-centric franchise
yeah you give you that make the league
have life as opposed to my team have
life like make the league have history
it goes back to
we want it to be your story and for it
to be your story the league has to be a
big character in there and the other the
other
teams and the other people in a
multiplayer league have to be part of
that story
um the hub is the most complex screen
madden's ever had
um just with the amount of information
that it brings to you all at once
um so we've spent a lot of energy on it
and we'll continue to spend energy on it
like how can we make your franchise more
usable more powerful
and more able to tell that story is a
big part of it so i would just add
everything's on the table you know
that's the good news as we said earlier
we're listening to the community we want
to hear feedback as we get into the
launch of the season
i think we've delivered two of the top
three most requested features in staff
management scouting you know so there's
some others out there and we'll hear
more as we go into the launch window
and we'll figure it out together yep yep
it's the summer we still have time
yeah we might even let you to come back
in the fall again to to talk about
that well i i think the question that
everybody
is wondering is have you guys talked
about what you're going to call men in
2025 because you've already used the
madden 25 thing is that discussion
happen
well we're going to talk to the
community about that okay good good
feedback
sure there will be suggestions well
gentlemen it has been an absolute
pleasure
talking about madden franchise but i
can't wait and i hope that people at
home
are as excited as i am and thank you for
joining us today for this exciting look
at madden nfl 22 franchise
and what's to come this year with
scouting make sure you stay up to date
to the making madden podcast
where you'll learn about upcoming
franchise features coming this madden
season more will come from the ea play
live spotlight series in the next few
days
you can also follow at ea on twitter or
go to ea.com for the latest updates
and don't forget ea play live is july
[Music]
22nd
[Applause]
[Music]
hmm yes
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
hi i'm amit catwalla from wired magazine
and welcome to spotlight
this is the last episode in the ea
series that connects you to the games
you love
and the people who make them leading up
to ea play live on july 22nd
ei have invited me to this discussion
about fifa 22. we're going to be talking
about the next gen tech that they're
using to make football even more
realistic
what a game we have in store for you
today the hype has been building
all week and the fans are pouring into
the stadium the tension
palpable stay with us we'll have all the
action for you live right here
on ea tv we've got a great panel of
developers from fifa here to join us
today
please introduce yourselves and your
history with fifa hi everyone i'm sam
rivera i'm the lead gameplay producer
and i've been at ea for 12
years i can tell you i'm a very
passionate fifa player i obviously
play the game a lot at work but also for
fun at home
and probably my biggest achievement in
fought was to reach division one in
rivals
however i got relegated it didn't last
for too long but still it's something
that i enjoy a lot just playing the game
and hi i am uh sean pedrick i'm a
gameplay producer also on fifa i've been
working at ea
for and on fifa for just over nine years
now before i joined ea and when i was
younger and much fitter i was a
professional football player in england
wales and
north america so i'm very passionate
about football and
obviously fifa so again like everybody
here i'm super excited to talk to you
about gameplay in fifa 22 today
i'm kancho dasgov the gameplay director
for fifa 22.
i've been a da for 14 years and i
absolutely love football
aside from that i'm really into the
skillful side of things one of my side
hobbies is called freestyle football so
i love juggling the ball doing all sorts
of tricks
i've worked on all of the skill moves in
the game that's one of my biggest
passions
hi i'm gabe zarrow i am the community
manager
uh global engagement for fifa and i come
originally from brazil so football is
kind of a religion for us
i played fifa for most of my life and i
can say that my biggest achievement on
fifa 21 was to get
elite three uh also division one really
really great to meet you all now i think
like all of you i've been playing fifa
for most of my life and i was really
excited for the next gen version
to come out when i reviewed fifa 21
there was a lot of
room to grow within the game and the
next gen so i'm really interested to
hear about the work you guys have been
doing to improve the game year on year
and how next-gen tech is changing fifa
22.
now one of the big changes that you've
made for fifa 22 on next gen is
hyper motion which is going to make
football and fifa feel way more
realistic but
can you tell me a bit about it what
exactly is hypermotion sound
hypermotion is a nexion exclusive
technology
powered by real football that brings
gameplay to the next level of realism
high promotion integrates advanced 11 vs
11 mocap
and machine learning for the first time
to create the most authentic
responsive and fluid experience on the
pitch so what does that mean exactly
what
what's this 11v11 mocap you're talking
about and
and how does machine learning kind of
come into that in the past we used to
capture animation in a mockup studio
through an
optical way of doing it and we used to
have maybe one
two three players and we would tell them
go to this direction
kick the ball in this direction so
advance 11 versus 11 motion capture
excellent suits allows us to for the
first time capture
22 professional footballers playing on
the pitch
in other words the data from these
players in the real football environment
it's where it's powering the motion of
players
and teams in fifa 22. so what does the
algorithm the machine lagging algorithm
do with all that data how does it
take all that data from that match and
all the other data that you have and
apply it to
the animations that are used in fifa 22.
our cutting-edge and proprietary machine
learning algorithm
learns from over 8.7 million frames
from the advanced 11 versus 11 mod cap
and then in real time
creates animation this animation creates
more
organic and fluid motion in a different
set of scenarios in the game so what
you're gonna see is players alternating
between different like let's say a short
step and then a longer step to properly
get into the position where he can kick
the ball
for either a pass or shot or just a ball
control and that just makes things look
and feel more like football motion is
more fluid because players in real life
they adjust their cadence they look at
the ball
they position their bodies to get there
to get to the ball
and that's what you see with this new
machine learning technology that we have
in the game in fifa 22.
can you tell me a bit more about this
match this 11v11 match because i think
we've all seen or fifa fans would have
seen videos of players doing motion
capture in those suits with the little
white dots on them but this was a full
game of football with all 22 players
wearing these suits right
so i remember you telling us a story
about the 11b11 in spain right like you
were hyping up the players
you were telling them go really hard
this is your chance to be in the game
and and what happened there that was a
very important part we told them look
this is the first
time we're putting people actually
playing this for professional players
playing football and this animation is
going to the game so go and try hard
and exactly at the end of the of the
game they were about to fight uh
it was it was very interesting but we
really got the data that we wanted you
see
that the data is more athletic now
there's more intensity
um physicality is there and also a lot
of behaviors that you don't usually get
with regular
motion capture players being more human
you get to
take all these behaviors and talking and
pointing directing people
you get all these little things all
these football behaviors now we have
them and we can put them
in the game which makes a more authentic
version of fifa and the other thing i
noticed was the emotion
there was a play i saw where the player
the player didn't get the ball
and he could tell he was so frustrated
like why didn't you pass the ball to me
and that was so natural just that the
way he did that emotion so we put that
into the game
it's crazy when you have one person in
the studio
so many cameras on this one person it's
it's hard to be as natural as with
22 people in one pitch right so exactly
so this is really changing how we
capture animation in football and it's
taking it to the next level
yeah i think another little component
that the country has touched on but that
i see when i when i looked at this xs
data was
just the natural behaviors that gabe was
touching on the physicality
that you couldn't get in the mocap shoot
that's more structured now you we see
players just naturally falling over each
other just sounds so simple but it's
actually quite hard to
to direct and say just fall over that
you need to
put it in a real environment and see the
players just come together naturally and
make these fall so that's just one part
of it but like there's so much more that
we we can gather from this sex scenes
data which which really elevates the
game
so it sounds like these new next-gen
consoles have really opened up the
ability to use
machine learning and use these new
technologies to make the game
more realistic cancer can you tell me a
bit more about the 11v11 game and what
exactly motion capture is adding to fifa
22 here yeah so the data captured from
this advanced 11v11 mocap shoot
actually has resulted in over 4 000 new
animations added to the game and just to
give you an idea that's three times more
animations
than we added last year so this is a
huge huge animation refresh
these animations show off the
footballing intensity the athleticism
the physicality of professional players
and this results in a huge improvement
in player motion
so this is a fundamental leap forward in
the way players move and
act and behave in the on the field you
know from your perspective as someone
who loves that skills-based approach and
loves the feeling of real football but
how does it actually make the game feel
different does the game feel more
responsive is it smoother
the game just looks more like football
than ever before players really feel
like professional footballers in the
game now
can you give me an example of what you
mean when you talk about animations
is this something like a player playing
a pass or a player making a tackle or
are they smaller than that is it smaller
actions or is it these kind of big
actions or both
so it's it's individual actions such as
a player switching the ball from one
side of the field to the other doing
that type of
lofted pass just the motion to slice
underneath the ball with your foot
the way professionals do it uh it's it's
quite unique
just to see that motion play out and and
follow the ball as it's flying through
the air so
these kind of moments in the game really
make the game uh
they make it feel more football because
you have the professional players
actually doing these actions in a match
will that differ depending on how good
the player is like will lionel messi
approach the ball differently to
a league two player or you know a player
from a lower division in fifa
there's definitely some personality in
terms of how we calculate how
how well the player can get into well
how fast there's multiple systems that
combine
to give you that fluidity messi will be
a little bit faster to get to the ball
however here is more not necessarily
about the personality is just about
knowing how you need to get to the ball
so when you put all the systems together
then yes players like messi players like
ronaldo they have a better sense of how
to shield how to position their body
so it can you can get away from the
defender obviously football isn't just
about individuals right it's also about
teams and tactics and there's
new features called team intelligence so
we're adding more team intelligence to
fifa 22. sean can you tell me a bit more
about that please
it's driven by the power of the new
generation of consoles tactical ai
creates deeper intelligence for all 22
players on the pitch
this starts with the attacking side of
things now in the attack
each of these players can have up to six
times more decisions per
second than ever before so now the
attacking runs are much more intelligent
and also
the build-up play in the the chance
creation the players make much more
supported runs which improves the level
of
tactics also the defensive side of
things is a big improvement too for
for tactical ai this was completely
rewritten this year so now the defensive
side of positioning team
do more zonal marking and defend as a
unit it looks like a real game on when
you're watching it on tv
like teams nowadays play very tactical
very structured formation so
we wanted to get that feeling across
into into fifa 22. you always tell me
keep your shape keep your shape don't
get out of position even when we're
playing together right
that's the most important thing that's
what i noticed in fifa 22.
like you see the the teams defensively
they move together as the ball
moves from one side of the field to the
other the defense moves together
yeah it's a big part of football
nowadays right he said like
work in previous fifa's maybe they would
work in twos and threes defending
whereas you really want the team to work
together and be more
zonal and and defend as a unit so so
yeah now you feel this straight away
when you when you boot up the game for
the first time in this example
shows the defensive rewrite of the
system um
you can see the back four working um as
a in a unit and as a zone or marking to
really work together from
when the ball switches from one side of
the pitch to the other side they shift
together as a team to really
work as a unit and defend that space we
analyze a lot of
professional football just to see how
teams uh
retain their shape when they are
defending when they move up the field
and that's what you are seeing in in the
game now which is just gives you that
feeling of more authentic experience
and actually in fifa 22 you can tweak
your attacking tactics so they're
different
depending on whereabouts on the pitch
you are right sean yeah of course yeah
you kind of nailed it with that one in
the attacking tactics you can
set your tactics in both chance creation
and build up play
which in other words means that if you
have the ball in your defensive half of
the pitch you can set your tactics to
play one way
possession football for example but then
when you play in the attacking side of
the pitch you can change to completely
different tactics so
gives the user and everyone more control
to adjust your tactics and customize
how you want to play this is a very
important feature especially for those
that play
competitively because you get more
control you can as you said
pick your tactics differently and it's
going to be an important one
so tactics is one thing and you know
we've all watched champions league
finals where it's like a chess game but
we've also all watched you know or at
least i've watched a lot of league two
football where it's more like a
wrestling match
how does high promotion improve the
physicality of players we've added
the new kinetic air battles so now when
the ball's in the air
you see the differences where two
players are synced together
so the visuals of two players going up
for the header look
way better than it ever has but also
maintaining the responsiveness of what
the user wants because you really need
to focus on the responsiveness as well
as the visuals so
these two things combine really elevates
the in airplay battles
in fifa 22. yeah and the thing about the
new headers right it's we're using the
two-player interaction technology
so now as you said we're syncing up two
players going up for the ball
so when they collide it actually looks
really natural the way they stumble or
fall
after that collision it's not like
individual
objects hitting each other this is like
two players really going up and battling
for the ball
so two players could be running side by
side jumping up for the ball they could
be backpedaling one guy could be running
in a certain direction the other guy in
the opposite direction but the point is
that they go up together you're gonna
feel that physicality now there's a
bunch of different areas of fifa that
are being touched by this hyper motion
technology and another one counter is
ball control which has really
benefited from these extra animations
players first touch is so important in
today's modern game
and high promotion gives us such a huge
animation refresh that now
we're able to control the bowl more
fluidly than ever before
and the way we're doing that is by
adding new multi-touch
animations and that's the key these
animations are longer
and they have multiple touches which
allows you to bring down a ball off the
chest
and onto your foot in one fluid motion
so with the longer animations you're
able to take the ball off your thigh
cushion it and turn quickly away from
your opponent you're gonna feel these
new animations
especially in controlling air balls so
anytime the balls in the air are
bouncing
you're going to take that quick touch
off your thigh or off your chest turn
fluidly with that second touch into into
the direction that you want to go in
we're calling this feature composed ball
control because the players are
way more natural at taking that first
touch and transitioning to the second
one look at the very start of this clip
you can see
a multi-touch trap if i'm not mistaken
where he's shielding the defender comes
off his thigh
it lands nicely in front of him to then
move forward and yeah that that part
to me uh looks looks looks great yeah
yeah and the thing is it's not just the
visual improvement it actually
allows the players to control the ball
quicker so one touch off the chest
setting it up for one touch on with the
foot and that's it you're off
it's not like in previous fifa's where
sometimes you take the ball off the
chest
it bounces awkwardly and you have to
like adjust it's way more responsive now
because it's literally
one touch two touch and you're off
that's so important right because
in on a competitive level on fifa you
see that
the best players they're just trying to
adjust for the best
shot or the best pass yeah and like in
professional
footballers also as well as countries
saying the realism in fifa
from an authentic point of view it's all
about the first touch like when you
coached as a kid or up until whatever
level you play at
always focus on the first touch getting
the ball out of your feet
one two touches and then you're away and
having all of these additional
animations there's over 400 new
animations for controlling the ball
just due to hypermotion and this is this
is just bringing a whole new level of
realism to the game that allow players
to turn
quickly away from their opponents and
just to add to that in the past we used
to prioritize
shorter animations to keep the game as
responsive as possible
however now this technology as cancer
mentioned allows us to
have longer animations with more than
one touch on each animation which result
in better visual quality
but we still have that ability to
transition out of that animation at any
time into something else
if the situation changes let's say
there's a defender coming and
in the middle of a trap that is very
long i need to go in a different
direction and we can transition out
so now we have the best of both worlds
responsiveness and good visuals
in the game and i just have to say that
out of all of the new animations in the
game that we got from high promotion
these are the ones that really stand out
to me
one of the other things that really
makes the game feel like real football
is the stuff that goes on off the ball
you know you've made real efforts to
humanize the players and to make them
not just stand there like mannequins
when they're not doing anything but to
look and behave and act like real
players would on the pitch
so when we analyzed the 11b11 advanced
mocap we actually noticed the players
are communicating all the time
i'm saying man on go here i'm offering
support
all these things that professionals do
all the time every second during a game
communicating talking so there's a lot
of
new behaviors that we've added players
just gesturing to each other saying like
hey i was free for a pass why didn't you
pass it to me or
look i'm going to go into this space
pass it to me there or
look watch out who's behind you these
are just some examples of the behaviors
that
we're adding to the game and some of
them are super subtle you may not pick
them up but you're kind of you're going
to get this general sense that players
are more alive
you know where you're going to notice
the most uh during set pieces like you
have a goal
you have a throw and players are talking
communicating asking for the ball
and they actually move a little bit to
provide you with better support so
you will have more passing options in
those deep free kicks for example
uh but it's all about this uh objective
of making players more human and just
smarter across the pitch we hear from
feedback
a lot that you know we have a parcel of
our player base that
talks about these animations so much
because they are
playing for an immersive experience the
career mode guys for example
they go wild with these types of things
it's incredible like the reception you
know for
this small pieces of animations that
just
create a more immersive experience for
those players it's
it's huge for them and the other thing
you'll notice about this clip is the way
holland runs we have a star specific
locomotion for uh erling highland he is
a big time player he's a young
superstar and the way he runs is so
unique he's kind of got this like a
little bit of a hunch in his posture and
big strides so to represent that power
and uniqueness of his running style
we've got
his his uh his running style in the game
now and the beautiful part of this is
their upper body layer animations
meaning
they don't hinder responsiveness you can
do whatever you want on the controller
these are just layers on top and also to
add a little bit extra from my
experience when this
thing came into the game when we played
it a couple of weeks ago it actually
makes you think about the game and play
it a little bit differently because
because now i might see a player off the
ball calling for the ball i'm like oh
maybe i should like think about passing
to this guy or
you know it just changes the way you
think and play the game a little bit
because you see these off-ball players
doing these gestures and
being more football so all this combined
just just
elevates the way you play play fifa and
gameplay yeah so so the animations
actually go to pretty much every area of
the game you see
goalkeeper you see the two-player
headers you see passes
shots ball control pretty much
everywhere all these
humanization gestures uh we are putting
those animations from the mock-up shoot
in uh every area of the game basically
that's so so fascinating one of the
things i remember
from writing about this in the past is
that the best midfield players
move their heads around much much more
than kind of average midfield players if
you measure how much javi or frank
manpod or steven gerrard or
a more modern midfield player moves
their head around when they're
when they're on the pitch and it's
really interesting how this kind of
in real football this upper body
movement actually has a direct
correlation
to how good a player is and how many
passes they play so it's really great to
see that being reflected in
fifa 22 as well now we've talked about
high promotion and how it changes
how it changes play but there's some
other developments in fifa 22 as well
and i'm just going to ask each of you to
name a couple of things that you're
excited about and excited to bring to
the fans in fifa 20 when it comes out
sean maybe you can go first yeah one of
the biggest things
um that we haven't talked about yet is
the new goalkeeper system
this new system unlocks much more
reliable saves for the goalkeeper as
well as making
smarter decisions in vital moments in
the game
to be honest that was the first thing i
noticed when playing fifa 22. it was
like i was playing i was like okay i
understand this is this is cool but when
the
the ball went to the goalkeeper he did a
completely new animation
it just stood out because i'm so used to
as a core player i'm so used to the
regular animations until fifa 21 and
then the first time he came out i was
like
wait what what's he doing it was really
stood out
yeah of course for the animations we've
completely added a bunch of new
animations to refresh how the keeper
looks as gabe was saying so
yeah and it's not just the animations
right the tech we're using you know to
play back those animations has been
upgraded
so as gabe mentioned the first thing you
notice is like oh my god that was so
much more fluid than
last year's game yeah even just the
small details about the way the
goalkeeper follows the ball as it passes
his hand that's all
much more realistic than it was before
so not only the full body animation of
the goalkeeper flying through the air
but the way his head is tracking the
ball as it
flies into the net kanji what are some
of the examples of things that people
might
not notice at first glance which appear
when you take a closer look
there's actually a lot of subtle
animations that have gone into the game
such as
the way you lay the ball off for the
first time pass to
even just doing a driven pass like one
of those daisy cutters
you know where you when you drive the
ball low and hard across the field
so you kind of notice these these new
ways to kick the ball and that's all
coming from that 11 b11 competitive
motion capture shoot that we did
we're calling this feature full team
authentic motion because
it's all about all those little bits of
animation that we're sprinkling into the
game
thousands and thousands of it and it
just brings the characters
more to life i'm amazed by the depth you
guys have gone to as well because it's
not just the player animations that have
been refreshed but you've really kind of
reworked the way the actual ball works
right
yeah that's actually a big one it's a
game-changing feature
so what we're doing in fifa 22 is we're
importing
real-world ball data into the game to
create the next level of realism in
terms of how the ball moves
so we are changing parameters like the
friction on the ground the friction with
the air
just how the ball spins the speed of the
ball
and that really changes the perception
of the game how the ball moves it's a
lot
more authentic and you notice that right
away
for example if you do a pass a love pass
to switch the field
the hang time of the ball is now more
obvious and really
so satisfying to do one of those uh love
passes
across the field and so again to put it
in context you do the pass you see a
brand new animation from the mocap
11 11 that we did then the ball flies in
a completely different way that is more
authentic
and then when the player is receiving
the ball those new long animations play
and that changes experience completely
yeah even just passing the ball around
simple ground passes
uh to your teammates they don't slow
down as much now right so you can
pass the ball turn past the ball turn
you're not like waiting for it to get to
you so
that just improves sort of the flow of
the game i found yep
definitely but if you do find yourself
you know one-on-one with an opponent and
everything slowed down and you're kind
of faced up
against them there was a new way of
getting past them on fifa 22 right
there's a mechanic called explosive
sprint when you press that right trigger
at the right time you're going to get a
bigger push
and acceleration with the ball now this
works both on dribbling
and defending so if you're trying to
catch up to a dribbler who maybe got a
step on you you're going to get that
boost
while while just running and sprinting
but if you're a dribbler you can
really lure that opponent in to get
close and get by him with a with a quick
acceleration that
changes the way you you defend and
attack
you've got to really think about now
when you you press that
sprint button you get the benefits of of
waiting and trying to have these mini
games between the attacker and the
defender
to really time these these inputs to to
see this explosion of sprint and
and both defenses and attacking side of
things so and one of the biggest
questions
around this feature is is it going to
make the game now op
the sprinting part of the game but no
that's exactly what we're tuning we are
making sure that
you feel that explosiveness but it's not
necessarily going to be the only way to
play so we're balancing things
considering
how players will be trying to use this
mechanic
yeah there is a cooldown you can't just
spam this mechanic
right so you can use it once but then if
you want to use it again you have to
wait some time
exactly i think we could talk about this
all day but i'd love to find out a bit
more about how you guys listen to the
fans
and the process that your dev team
undergoes to deliver on the feedback
that you guys
get we have a huge player base with
millions and millions of players around
the world
and it's it's a lot of different
priorities from these different types of
players
so we have different platforms and
initiatives
uh to take care of that feedback so for
example the game changer network we talk
directly to influencers content creators
and feedback specialists we have the
fifa community design
council which is a group that is
completely focused on
getting feedback early on the
development stages of the game
we have pro players being part of that
console we have
content creators that are focused on
foot we have people that are completely
focused on career mode
we have a couple of casuals and we have
you know
the average fifa player which could fall
into different categories as well
the idea there is for us to give them as
much information
as early as possible so that they can
interact directly with the producers and
uh
actually give some feedback before we go
into the depths of development
sam can you tell me a bit about what
it's like working with the feedback that
you get from the fans via gabe
after listening to all the ideas from
the fans all the feedback we also look
[Music]
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
i love love love that video what's up
everyone i'm alex ackerman
and i'm andy mcnamara and you are
watching the 2021 ea play live pre-show
concert for cows that's got to be a
first but probably my favorite way to
open a show
ever the latest expansion for sims 4
cottage living is out
today so go get your cross stitch on and
check it out after the show
all right in just a few minutes the ea
play live main event is coming with all
the news sweepstakes and surprises you
know and love
but first we want to take a moment to
recap all the news that's been revealed
this summer
and what a summer it's been oh yeah i
personally have done nothing else but
play mass effect legendary edition
i think you actually mean romance garrus
or
maybe that's just me it's been a huge
summer regardless for ea originals the
talented joseph fares and the team over
at hayes light
gifted us the critically acclaimed and
my personal favorite
it takes two millions of you have been
dodging
with dodgeballs and velen's knockout
city and the soon to be released lost in
random was an official tribeca film
festival selection
congrats to the zoink team we can't wait
to play and for those
who haven't yet been acquainted with
their magical world let's take a look at
the story trailer for lost and random
let's
welcome to the world of random
where everyone's destiny is decided
by a roll of the one true dice
and the one true queen who controls it
but when a child comes of age they must
rule this dice
just once and in so doing determine
their fate
for all eternity happy birthday
be grateful child that the queen herself
is here for your special day
now roll the dice and let's see what
kind of person
you truly
[Music]
where is this place
are you
[Music]
i haven't seen a real one in years
i'm supposed to say something important
you know nothing
[Music]
you tell me where my sister is
where are you i'm coming for you sis
[Music]
my queen
that trailer gives me the chills i think
every time we watch it
stay tuned for more on lost and random
including an exclusive first look at
combat gameplay later on in the main
show
speaking of combat i can tell you as a
part of the team over respawn that apex
will be showing up later today in a
pretty big way of course battlefield
2042 has some big news to share as well
but you would already know that if you
tuned into the ea play spotlight series
over the last few weeks we've gathered
creative leaders from across the ea
studios to share their insights
and some exciting news yeah we did here
are a few of the highlights
we kept the game a secret and did the
beyonce drop always go with beyonce
flawless exactly hypermotion is a
nextion exclusive technology
powered by real football that brings
gameplay to the next level of realism
high promotion integrates advanced 11 vs
11 mocap
and machine learning for the first time
to create the most authentic
responsive and fluid experience on the
pitch
scouting as a whole is being revamped so
you start things off
essentially by getting a baseline
scouting on every player
and one of the big goals i had was i
wanted to add complexity to the feature
but i wanted to remove some of the
tediousness of it
i think we're having a sort of golden
age at the moment where this freedom is
allowed and
people like myself can start to see
themselves coming through in these
stories
and i i hope that authenticity isn't
lost you know i think uh that's exactly
why we're
in these studios because that
authenticity is worth the struggle
it's worth fighting for you need to ask
people for a bit of faith to
stick with the idea and just stay with
it and okay we're not sure what it will
be and they will be like you know what
go for it they give you that space and
room to play which is so
so beautiful and rare to see now is the
time to make something totally great and
unique it's hard in a movie today
because it's been going on for a long
time
how come you get all the cool gadgets
what should fans expect from battlefield
2042 at ea play live so i think it's
that mo that was on the whiteboard
for many decades and many years and
never kind of happened and now christian
is team and they have been
you know orchestrating and building it
so christian i'm hoping that the
the players the community will will
really embrace and like what we're going
to show them
lars mr battlefield gustafsson who is
jumping around
on this zoom chair so get a sturdy car
ready to watch it
if you're a fan of first person shooters
ea originals sports or gaming in general
the spotlight's had
something for everyone if you haven't
yet go check those out on our youtube
channel
there's a ton of great content there
there is and speaking of ea sports it's
been a big month for fifa news
so let's treat ourselves for another
look at the fifa 22 trailer
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
i'm never gonna face it
andy i need to correct myself that was
not a treat that was a
feast beast a feast and fifa fans
you have to check out the fifa spotlight
which offered a deep dive into
all the updates coming to fifa 22. now
fifa won't have news to share
in the main show because we're going to
give it to you right now
unbelievable yes fans of fifa ultimate
team already know that this year
some fan favorite footballers are
returning in the form of fifa
ultimate team heroes nine of them have
been revealed so far and right now we're
going to share
two more okay first up it's heroic
premier league striker turn manager
ollie gunner sulshar and second
a fireman from the rhineland it's lars
ricken
and who doesn't like lars there's more
where that came from
and remember if you pre-order the
ultimate edition before august 11th you
will get a bonus
ultimate team heroes pack and of course
ea play members get their hands on the
game early
yes they do but that is just one benefit
of being a member
an ea play membership is your ticket to
getting more from your favorite ea games
including
fantastic in-game rewards and exclusive
content than all of these upcoming
titles
and speaking of rewards we'll be giving
away a whole mess of great prizes during
the main show
including gear from logitech polaris
plus thousands of game codes
and ea play memberships yes so make sure
to stay tuned to the main show for your
chance to win
and if you haven't already make sure to
link your twitch nea accounts
yes that's right because i personally
have
hand hand-coded an apex legends jump
master weapon charm
thank you for that you're very welcome
that you can earn just by watching the
show on twitch
so apex fans stick around because you
are not going to want to miss a closer
look at the latest legend
coming to the apex games if you don't
know who i'm talking about we got our
first look at sear
just a few days ago check it out
this
[Music]
it has been seen
a woman will rise bearing the mark of
the moths
[Music]
our firstborn will be a cursed child
his eyes drawing us
all to the flame
refuse the child's gaze
for the undone one glance
will reduce a mountain to dust
a key to a beggar
and an ocean to a desert
everything he touches will be changed
[Music]
this it cannot be
unseen
wow the apex team is getting wilder and
wilder with those
lore trailers i can't wait to see more
trust me you're not alone i
love that trailer but we have a lot more
coming up during the main show that
you're not gonna want to miss
and that is now mere moments away but
one last recap from us featuring one of
the newest members of the ea sports
family
codemasters yes you'll know them best
from their incredible slate of racing
titles like dirt
grit and the f1 series whose latest
installment just dropped a few days ago
if you follow f1 you know it's been an
absolutely crazy year so far with some
amazing rivalries
well if you want to put yourself right
in the middle of that cody's is here to
make that dream a reality
let's drop straight into the action with
the f1 2021 trailer
nice i just don't get it so he
gets to pit ahead of me and they give
his car the only new power unit last
season
and he gets to go out
we'll have more from codemasters coming
up in just a few seconds
we're about to begin and i personally
cannot wait for you to see what
battlefield 2042 has in store
i've been andy mcnamara i think you
still are andy mcnamara and i'm alex
sacrament thank you
so much for tuning in and enjoy the show
it is going to be awesome
yeah it is
[Applause]
[Music]
coming to you from los angeles
california
this is ea play live 2021
i'm your host wwe superstar xavier woods
aka
austin creed and we have an amazing show
for you today
we've got world premiere gameplay
exclusive first looks
including a brand new multiplayer
experience for battlefield 2042
and a few more surprises they won't even
let me tease
plus just like last year we've got some
amazing prizes to give away
so keep an eye out throughout the show
for hidden letters they'll spell out a
secret code that you'll need at the end
of the show
if you want a chance to win polaris gear
logitech gadgets and thousands of codes
for great ea games including
mass effect legendary edition dirt 5 and
more so let's get to it
ea has long played home to fan favorite
racing titles from
need for speed to burnout to real racing
and now that the experts at codemasters
are
joining the ea family that incredible
lineup just got supercharged
with the addition of franchises like
grid dirt
project cars and f1 so if you like
racing
if you like being in the driver's seat
you're gonna love
what codemasters has cooked up for us
today but first
let's take a quick look at what they do
[Applause]
best
i was just a little girl when i started
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
joining us now from london is
codemaster's senior game designer becky
crossdale
welcome becky hey austin hey now i heard
that you might have a little surprise
for us today
yes i do and i don't know if you can
tell austin but i am so
excited because on behalf of the entire
code masters team
this is the world premiere trailer for
grid legends
160 take 13 common
ten teams dozens of drivers only one
can become champions my name is yume
tanaka my goal is to become the first
woman ever to win the championship they
know who i
am i'm nathan mccain
five-time grid series world champion
soon to be six times
and that's a new record
if this grid legal i can build it to win
touring cars muscle cars open wheel
drift best team
best car and win by having the money
by having the guts and if these idiots
can't keep their cars on the track it's
their problem
people when you keep pulling up there
that stops
or you're gonna get somebody hurt
hopefully it'll be you
bring it on baby
becky this this looks incredible on top
of the gameplay
in the cars and the environments now
we've got all these characters that seem
to have different motivations i'm
already incredibly invested
it looks like you guys are really up in
the ante on storytelling well
first and foremost the grid series has
always been about delivering gameplay
excellence
and with grid legends you are still
getting that same immersive racing
experience that you know
and love but this time we are taking
things up a notch
and we're adding another layer on top of
that we are really proud of this new
story mode
well i i do love a good story and i feel
like i've seen a lot of those faces
somewhere before
yet we had the absolute pleasure of
working with the incredibly talented
shooty gagwa
who plays the wonderful eric in
netflix's sex education
we also captured the entire thing using
extended reality or xr
where if you've been watching disney's
and mandalorian you will have seen that
tech in action
it's what they used to create those
incredible worlds well it sounds amazing
but this obviously isn't racing in space
right
no we are using this tech to draw you
further
into this racing experience we really
want to bring you
deeper into the grid world than ever
before
it's also been really great for our
actors because they're acting against
something that's visually there
it's not the same as green screen or
motion capture
they are stepping into our grid world
and reacting with it
it sounds great can you give us any
hints on the story or would that be
spoilers
without any spoilers um we are giving
you a classic
underdog tale we were putting you
straight into the driver's seat
right in the middle of the grid world
series where you'll be facing off
against the
all dominant raven west team that is a
team that does not like to share the
tarmac
and for the rest of the story well you
just have to wait and see
but let's talk gameplay uh we saw a new
big range of vehicles in that trailer
can you talk about those a little bit
oh yeah there are so many vehicles we
are giving you big rigs stadium trucks
drift cars
open wheelers muscle cars electric cars
we are giving you
hyper cars like the aston martin
valkyrie have you seen that car
and we are also giving you multi-class
mixed racing
which means that you can take any of
those cars and put them together on the
same track
whoa i just saw a big rig take out an
open wheeler in the trailer and i i love
it
so is there anything else that you can
tell us about grid legends
without giving too much away there is
a ton of new stuff for the fans to sink
their teeth into
including some new modes such as boost
mode and elimination mode
we've also got some fancy new locations
like the
iconic city of moscow we've also got
the beautiful city of london as well as
you can drive right past buckingham
palace or you could travel to the
stunning estrada alpena and take one of
our beautiful hypercars
to its limit all right well you heard it
here first
storytelling and extended reality mixed
class racing new modes new locations
this is beyond exciting so becky thank
you so much for your time
no thank you austin of course all right
folks
so we're just getting started we've seen
grid legends
and now it's time for a different breed
of legend
two years ago apex legends came out of
nowhere and now 100 million players and
17 legends later it just
keeps getting bigger we've got more
modes more maps more platforms for play
and of course more legends
so what's next for apex well today
we have answers ladies and gentlemen
i give to you apex legends
emergence
change i see it in everything
i see it in a boy rocked by tragedy
transform his pain and defy reality
i see it in the warrior who must choose
between their new life
and the annihilation of their home
i see it in a girl tortured by revenge
embrace hope when love awakens her heart
i see it in me a boy born under a bad
woman
turn his tail
into a legend
change is relentless
but that does not mean it cannot be
beautiful
[Music]
and take comfort
nothing lasts forever
you must adapt
surrender
and embrace your true nature
know that you are not alone
change comes for us all
but this chaos has purpose
all of us thrown together
[Music]
so the flame can burn its brightest
change fight it
and fall
accept it and rise above
wow i'm standing here like slack-jawed
watching this
because there's so much to unpack from
that trailer so let's go ahead and meet
the man with all
the answers apex game director chad
grenier
so happy to have you here chad thanks
austin happy to be here uh before we get
started and get into it i want to give a
shout out to the amazing developers at
respawn
hey all right well a subset of them uh
if you love apex it's because of these
amazing developers that are
working hard uh creating apex legends
for us
well big love to the whole respawn team
especially whoever came up with lifeline
cause that's
my girl but okay there's a lot for us to
talk about but you know i'm geeked about
zer so can you tell us some more about
his abilities
i saw this man stare through walls he's
got drones coming out of his chest
please tell me about his kit yeah
similar to bloodhound
seer is all about tracking enemies but
in a different way and has a very unique
kit
so while you're aiming down the sights
you'll have a heartbeat sensor that will
give you hints as to
where an enemy might be if you think
you've located them you can use your
tactical
which sends out some of those drones out
of your chest and will actually reveal
and track
the enemy's location the ultimate is
really powerful especially in certain
gameplay situations you can send out
hundreds of micro drones
and create a sphere around an area that
you choose and
all enemies that are moving quickly to
that space are tracked
i love when there's new abilities that
kind of change the game
because this game obviously is always
changing always evolving and whenever
there's a new legend
there's always an interesting shift in
the meta so with those incredible
abilities how do you think that sears
going to change the game
yeah again i mentioned bloodhound also
as a tracker
but unlike bloodhound seer is about very
precise and lingering information
so he's a bit more of a stealth oriented
legend
and you're gonna see i think some
interactions because of that sphere i
mentioned his ultimate
if you're moving quickly through that
space your footsteps are revealed
but now if you're walking slowly you can
avoid the the detection
and so i think you'll see some
interesting gameplay experiences and new
ways to play
yeah with slowing it down a bit yeah it
sounds like once the ring gets tight
especially
you're gonna have a lot of new ways to
play this game
um but this past season for instance it
felt like apex
really moved beyond battle royale with
the introduction of arenas
so what's the reaction been like for you
guys the fan reaction has been really
great uh we've seen a lot of players
enjoy arenas which is which is awesome
we're really excited to finally have a
way to play apex legends beyond battle
royale
and uh yeah people are loving it so
we've got new maps in the works
and uh some other things come in i don't
want to you know talk about just yet
but we've got a lot planned for arenas
all right fair fair well
i do know that you guys announced ranked
arenas are coming as well so can you
give us some information on that
yep so we've got one season of arenas
under our belts now
we wanted to make sure that we were
seeing how players were adapting to the
mode
make sure to get the balance right make
sure that the the price and the economy
is correct
and now we'll be introducing the ranked
mode in emergence
so it's a bit of a different ranked
system than we have in in the battle
royale mode
so we're really excited for you to get
your hands on it well it's really cool
to see apex always
doing new things like for instance uh
leaning into the competitive scene with
things like the apex legends global
series so are we gonna see
more of the algs absolutely we just
ended year one of algs our championships
recently
concluded and it was amazing there's
like so many tactics and
amazing plays in there many teams were
fighting for the championship in the
last round we hit record numbers so
we're really excited in september to be
kicking off year two of the lgs
and for the first time we're gonna be
inviting playstation
and xbox players to compete alongside
the pc players
really see who's best and an all new
league format so
um we have more information at
playapex.com
algs well i am beyond looking forward to
it and chad before you go
i have to ask when can we see more from
seer
we've got an awesome gameplay trailer
coming on monday
and emergence drops on august 3rd and
for now
i can show you a finisher of course
please please
this game demands so much of us
[Applause]
but from you she demands
everything yeah that's
that's all i need to see it's just it's
so awesome
but chad thank you so much for being
here thanks austin of course
of course and again big shout out to the
whole respawn team
now for the apex fans watching us on
twitch today respawn is hooking you up
with an exclusive
jump master gun charm so make sure
you've got your twitch
and ea account linked and keep watching
the show to earn that drop
but that's not the only thing we're
giving out today
keep an eye out for the hidden letters
that spell out a secret phrase because
at the
end of the show we'll give you a link
where you can enter that code for your
chance to win some great prizes
including codes for ea originals like
knockout city
and it takes two
so speaking of originals let's head
across the ocean for some stop motion
and check out a soon to be released ea
original
lost in random
[Music]
and just like that young austin found
himself
introducing a new segment hello
he stored bewildered by the voice coming
from somewhere unknown
somewhere random
uh okay all right anyway uh it's coming
soon and it looks
really cool austin stopped himself i had
forgotten to mention
the tribeca film festival selection it
was a
selection at the tribeca film festival
he tried the line again more
enthusiastically
look man i'm trying to run a whole show
you're enthusiastically
really selling it could you just let me
intro the segment
thank you i am
it was an official tribeca film festival
selection this summer and it's coming
soon
joining us from gothenburg sweden to
tell us more is zoink creative director
olav redmon
hello austin how's it going olaf thank
you so much for joining us and
congratulations on tribeca
it's so cool to see video games right
next to movies being regarded as they
should be
thank you austin i i'm so proud of the
song team and what we've accomplished
and
i'm so happy about the selection because
lost in random is really inspired by all
these
movies that i grew up with and stop
motion animation and dark fairy tales
and
and at sonic we're always trying to push
narrative in video games so i'm
so happy yeah well i i can't wait to see
more
oh love of my life what do you have for
us today
i'm super pleased to share a first look
at one of our most unique aspects of los
angeles gameplay
dice battle which is an exciting
explosive blend of real-time action and
time stop tactics
where every roll of the dice unleashes
incredible powers out of the head
of your jack-in-the-box buddy dicey well
it
sounds awesome so let's take a look
once upon a time there were two devoted
sisters
named even and ord
cruelly separated by an evil queen
and the roll of a dice
together with this little fella
even was determined to rescue her
beloved sister
[Music]
come on dicey
in this strange and fascinating world of
random
adventure and combat go hand in hand
and many peculiar characters await
some will help you mean
this one and some won't that's against
our rules
[Music]
oh sure a little girl with a dice
those coins can be traded for cards dogs
i've got cards here the greatest cards
in the land
[Music]
cards contain new attacks abilities
and more all of which
come in handy during dice battle
ready even uses her slingshot to attack
deadly foes this can knock off energy
cubes
used to feed the strange companion dicey
and once fully charged even can rule
dicey
and freeze time itself
let's see how she uses it
[Music]
well done even nice
that was a good one
even's quest would take her across all
six realms of random
even must roll the dice and play the
odds
but just a chance at saving her sister
[Music]
random rules long macy's
just from that alone i
already need to play this game it looks
so cool
uh but what can you tell me about these
these combat cards that we're seeing
cars are just fun part of dice battle
but i love the way they look so i
brought a few examples to show off
oh okay awesome what are we looking at
here then so as you saw
cards can be selected during combat that
unleash new powers and abilities like
this one for instance
explosive dice which turns dicey into
this ticking time bomb
but you just gotta be careful so it
doesn't blow you up keep your distance
and where's this hammer of two let's use
summon a giant hammer
which also gives even super strength to
be able to swing it around
offensive maneuvers i like it but it's
not just about orphans like we have also
for instance uma's blessing which comes
from uma this old hidden
witch and she provides a bubble shield
to protect even
and that's just a taste like there's a
lot of different powers at your disposal
some
curse enemies some heal even or create
traps
some arenas also work as giant board
games affected by rolling dicey so
you're gonna have to try different
tactics to conquer the queen's giant
mad tabletop themed arenas all right
olav obviously
my next question you know it's coming
when can we play this game
yeah my favorite question lost in random
releases on september 10th on pc
console and nintendo switch and you can
pre-order starting right after the show
and if you want a dicey companion of
your own he'll be available to ea play
members as a gun charm in one of my
current favorites
apex so keep an eye out for that well
you all heard it here first
and olav thank you so much for joining
us today it has been my absolute
pleasure austin and welcome to random
thanks well there you have it
lost in random is coming soon but
there's another ea original that's
already here
and it's bringing that throwback
playground heat to the masses
that's right i'm talking about knock out
city oh oh okay
dropped earlier this year knockout city
has had one hell of a summer
and they're just getting warmed up here
with more is karthik bala from velen
studios in new york
thanks austin we're so grateful to our
community for the massive response to
knockout city
with millions of new brawlers hundreds
of thousands of crews
and nearly a billion kos landed your
response has really been
a knockout as an indie team dedicated to
taking creative risks
having all of you embrace this unique
thing we've made
is an amazing feeling and i just want to
say
thank you at launch we promised you new
features and updates
that keep the game fresh and exciting
today
i'm here to deliver on that promise on
behalf of the whole velen studios team
it's my absolute thrill to present
knockout city
season two fight at the movies
in a world of chaos where mayhem
rules the streets is anyone strong
enough
to stop the unstoppable
a world where one hero rises to meet
instant regret
a world where lovers chase their
passions
and feel the burn
a world where terror lurks high
above
where warriors fight for dodge brawl
supremacy
and teensy tiny brawlers battle it out
in a child's bedroom
this season bring your moves to the
movies
coming july 20
oh man that voice is murder on the pipes
the hollywood drive-in opens july 27th
we'll see you at the movies it's
showtime
you saw we got new skins we got a new
ball knockout city baby
season two arrives july 27th and
remember you can play for free
up to street rank 25 so get in you might
come across me and my crew we're called
that baseline you won't beat us because
we're really good
but you'll have fun and right now it's
available on
all platforms with cross play so if you
haven't yet go ahead get in there and
give it a whirl
all right everyone the moment that you
have been waiting for
is here
you've seen the trailers you've read the
hot takes and you already know that
battlefield is back baby
you hear me it's back battlefield is
back it's a bad outfield
i can't wait to wingsuit surfer tornado
this game is gonna be so good
and in just a moment we're revealing a
brand new battlefield 20 42 experience
but first
for those who haven't been paying
attention here's what you've been
missing out on
god that's so cool
that's the coolest thing i've ever seen
this is awesome do it
on behalf of our entire team we hope
you're thrilled with what you've seen so
far from battlefield 2042
but this is just the beginning we have
so
much more to show you battlefield 2042
is built up by three epic experiences
firstly of course all that warfare that
we showed you earlier
secondly hazard zone that will show off
later this year
and now a new community driven
experience that we're happy to share
with you
today built by our old friends over at
triple effect
formerly dice la it's an experience
designed from community feedback it's an
experience we've dreamt about building
for
over a decade so let's have a look
[Music]
you gotta step it up boys
that's the sound of the drone
[Music]
going back
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
luntable
is
this looks incredible there's so many
crazy things happening in this trailer
we got knives versus defibrillators we
got soldiers from every air i have
so many questions so let's bring on an
expert here to help us out is the
general manager of ripple effect
we've got christian grass welcome
christian hey austin thanks for having
me super excited to be here of course
thank you for being here
now that trailer absolutely ridiculous
like what the hell did we just see so
what you just saw was the battlefield
portal it's a new community driven
experience that gives players the
freedom
to write their own rules and shape their
own battlefield
you can mix and match content from
battlefield 1942
back company 2 bf3 and battlefield 2042
to create brand new game modes then you
can share and discover those on the
portal platform and that's just what's
coming at launch this is a real love
letter to the fans
from our incredible team and oh oh and
this is your squad
yes this is the fantastic ripple effect
team and they deserve all the credit in
the world for creating this
great experience we've had so much fun
bringing back some of the most beloved
vehicles
gadgets weapons and maps from past
titles
well thank you all huge huge credit to
this amazing team and
everyone who's made battlefield 2042
possible all right so to bring it back
when you say
beloved maps we're talking caspian
border yes eureka harbor
yes el alamein yes el alamein is also
included it's actually my all-time
favorite map
plus we have no shark canal battle of
the bulge
and valparaiso and of course
all seven of the new epic scale maps
already announced for 2042
they're also playable in portal i love
it i love it but this is more than just
maps right
absolutely portal is a chance for the
community to drive the platform there's
a whole slate
of customization options and even an
advanced logic editor for you to play
around with
tools that were previously only
available to us on the development team
so that trailer it was just packed with
a ton of crazy moments
so i'm curious how wild can we actually
get with portal
you can get pretty wild yeah okay so can
i pit
world war ii against 2042 yes
okay okay uh what about game modes can i
make an infection mode
where it's me against a ton of super
fast soldiers with knives
absolutely okay uh what about shoddy
snipes but
but not just regular shoddy snipes like
like like a gun game with a whole bunch
of shoddy snipes from all throughout
history
that is a very specific idea there
austin but yes actually you can
baton three for three bring it home can
i play
as a penguin with a flamethrower a
penguin with a flamethrower yeah
no i mean look there are some limits
it's not a level editor you can't edit
the maps themselves
and no you can't play as a penguin with
a flamethrower all right that's that's
fine
it's fine i had to ask but it does sound
like there's a ton
to play around with oh yes the options
are pretty deep and we're committed to
working with the community
to build out this suite of tools and
content as the game evolves
we want this experience to go where you
want to take it
we see this sandbox as a big part of the
future of battlefield 2042.
well i assume that the community is
going to have a field day with this
i really hope players will embrace
portal that's who we built it for
in fact we gave a sneak peek to a few
members of the community
to see what they could come up with oh
okay i assume my invitation got lost in
the mail but that's fine that's fine
let's check it out two teams and two
vips
but only one way to score this is vip
fiesta by courage
it's the u.s factions of battlefield 3
and bad company 2
facing off on erica harbour with 24
players
and random loadouts die and you'll
redeploy with an all-new loadout
track down the enemy vip and make it
count
all bring the power of 2042 to caspian
border
and take on the forces of 1942 this
is quality versus quantity by gabitron
a small squad from 2042 are taking on 32
players from 1942
the future's got the hardware but the
past got the numbers
destroy those mcoms
but do it before your tickets are up and
you're not getting them back
unless you clear the sector
not enough memes fine set up on orbital
for the fight of your lives
with robot man by redacted
20 duck sized eod bots one horse-sized
t-91
settle your battlefield debates on who
wins what
come on dude robot man what this looks
so much fun
but i need to know just pretend like the
cameras aren't here just mean you
who's redacted can't tell you that sorry
but what i can tell you is that we're so
excited for the players
to create or simply discover their
favorite new way to play battlefield
and we can't wait to explore and try out
the thousands of experiences
our community will build once they have
the tools in their hands
and we get our hands on portal at launch
right yes porter will be available
at launch day one along with a bunch of
pre-made modes for you to try right away
okay this is this is fantastic but
christian before you go
let me make sure that i have all of this
straight so on top of all the content
and maps that have already been
announced
we also get content from battlefield
bad company to and battlefield 3
including six of the best maps of
all time and all that can be sliced
diced and mixed together in portal
and then we still have hazard zone
coming later this year
yes that's exactly what i'm telling you
austin if you've always been a fan or if
you've never played battlefield before
we want battlefield 2042 to be the
ultimate battlefield experience
christian
just just thank you thank you my
pleasure austin
i'll see you on the battlefield all
right so portal looks incredible and we
could end things there
but i don't think we're done jess yet
we're gonna leave you with one more
surprise first though you remember that
secret code
i hope you were paying attention because
all the letters have been revealed so
if you want to win some awesome games
and gear stick around because we're
gonna give you the link to enter in just
a second
but for now come with me
i hope you've enjoyed the show as much
as i've enjoyed being your host
now my name is austin creed and our last
reveal is somewhere
in there
but you know what why don't you go first
[Music]
okay
so
[Music]
you